and we're live cheers sir your brother
yeah why the world is on fire we might
as well get it off
I've been Celine I've been clean for
seven days no booze no nothing no
nothing look good your face looks good I
know I can starting to see a direct
difference when I quit drinking do you
feel trapped by your image so your party
image I would never have said yes until
this week I've exhaled for the first
time in a very big way like where I was
like okay no Road I'm not I'm not doing
social media I'm doing stories at stuff
I'm not trying to put I like when things
shut down I kind of shut down with
America and I was like yesterday man I
sat in a hammock sober for like [ __ ]
two hours and just relaxed it is nice to
be home for a while it is nice you
realize what a beating our lifestyle
takes on your body the travel and then
if you're boozing to the travel and the
boozing together so Wow we should tell
everybody what we learned today I'm
revising my thinking about this virus
because of Michael yo Michael yo caught
it Michael yo is healthy as [ __ ] he's
he's not he's not any high-risk group
like he's not he doesn't have any
pre-existing conditions he's in shape
and he got it and he got pneumonia too
and he said it was a double combination
and he thought he was gonna die and he
was in the hospital for over a week and
four days ago he said he thought he was
gonna die that's [ __ ] terrifying cuz
Michael yo is healthy he's not some 80
year old man I talked to my friend dr.
Peter Tia he's a physician and he swam
from momwhat Maui yes he swam all the
islands he's a [ __ ] straight-up
savage so his take this is my question
to him I said this is crazy [ __ ] what is
your take on how so many people
experience very few symptoms but others
get wrecked and he said I still think
most people below 55 sail through it
I've had two patients get it
shitty cold and loss of a sense of smell
and taste which
we return soon but still a small
fraction of these folks get hurt I know
a doctor care of a 28 year old fitness
instructor on a ventilator in New York
City today why he said may be some
genetic predisposition we know blood
types matters a is the worst o is the
best based on antibodies Sam
he said I'm all positive he said but I
don't think that explains more than some
of it maybe [ __ ] like vaping he said
still too soon to tell he is a straight
up no nonsense no [ __ ] guy and I
listen to everything he says
so when guys like him are concerned I
get concerned and he's concerned he's
had a weird disease another thing that
he said it's weird that it seems that
people who spend more time with this get
it worse he's like it's not like you
know like like doctors and hospitals
with prolonged exposure get it really
bad nurses in hospitals with prolonged
exposure seem to get it really bad
whereas some people get it and they
don't get it bad it's weird it's a very
very strange disease according to
doctors and I think we're still trying
to figure this out you know it's just
wow it's it's one of those things where
everyone's just sort of absorbing the
information as it comes in and you got
to be open to adjusting your opinions in
my opinions were I really was concerned
with old people and I was concerned with
sick people
now after Michael Young I'm like okay
this is not that straightforward there
might be some some other crazy factors
here like for some people yeah like
Idris Elba who looks fantastic you know
fine but maybe other people are gonna
have a real hard time with it like
Michael yo Michael he was not sickly guy
he's a big robust guy that's a spooky
one yeah I mean your podcast with the
osterholm chicle it Chicken Little that
scared the [ __ ] out [ __ ] sitting in
the back of my tour bus and then hear
this I'm like ah I've had a few
cocktails I had a joint let's go to bed
oh cool who's this guy ah the
coronavirus I would mind hearing a
little bit about that holy first thing I
did I told Jamie first thing I did i sat
up in bed and I was googled that
[ __ ] I was like you
a book didn't he [ __ ] that guy like I
was guys I was so freaked out in that
[ __ ] podcast what's crazy about
osterholm is he predicted this [ __ ]
literally specifically as to where it
was gonna come from
he was very insightful you mean [ __ ]
that guy in a bad way very insightful
dude and it was a great podcast but man
it's I'll tell you right now Joe you
said you said so guys that are
overweight to drink a lot this smoke I
was talking to you you know that right
by the way I thought you were I'm
talking to you I didn't want to say it
but I was like piecing together at all
my good friends who's my one for him
takes care of himself the worst it's you
it's me it's you I quit cigars weed
beautiful booze I'm gonna drink now but
they're still okay man like if you
stopped this bus now and got healthy and
just drank water only water for a month
you know you could pull this [ __ ]
together
I'm poorly your health relatively
speaking compared to the [ __ ]
savagery you do your physique to your
body to to your form to your being by
just downing booze constantly you're
great like most people would be really
[ __ ] up if they were in your position
that's we were all um we were marveling
when you ran that marathon release its
[ __ ] parties so hard and he just
ran a marathon like it's crazy
you're a very like I hate to use the
same morning but it's the right word
robust you're a robust guy and the
reason why you're able to endure all
this booze is because you're robust but
if you didn't do the booze man you'd
probably a stud because whatever the
[ __ ] is keeping you going with all this
booze imagine what kind of me you're
like pouring sugar water into a [ __ ]
68 Charger pinch up clean that [ __ ] up
replace the heads that Hemi will purr
you know like you you must be you have
to have great genes there's no other way
I mean how old you now 47 yeah you're 47
and relatively speaking compared to the
[ __ ] savagery you do booze and I
posed with you it's it's it's a rough go
now it's like smoking
with Joey Diaz or would be real from
Cypress Hill just stop you're not in
their league you don't roll with Hicks
and Gracie and expect to tap them I
don't know you don't smoke we would be
real I didn't I didn't see I never I
never see that and then I took Norman
Don to Europe with me mark Norman mm-hmm
and Mark Norman's a Boozer yeah a man
two days in the tapped out
we got him addicted ambien he was he is
the funniest [ __ ] human being I
really love him he's a real comic man I
cherish guys like him him Andrew Schultz
attention to these young guys coming up
or everything to me Chris coming up to
do you are you you know Krista Stefano I
do not know him what I know of him he
makes funny giggles fine walk very funny
guy there's a good crop a good crop of
real comics who honor this thing that we
do is it's a weird thing we do you know
it's like what we're doing is a very
strange game of saying funny silly [ __ ]
and then trying to make each other laugh
and then but understanding what we're
doing and don't say oh you really mean
that or oh you know you can't joke about
this like no those guys will do that
because we know the game the game is to
be funny that's the sister game be funny
and you sometimes you say ridiculous
[ __ ] to be funny sometimes it works
sometimes it falls apart but sometimes
it blows up in your face and sometimes
it knocks it out of the park and so you
got to take those risks and you throw in
every now and then it's the people that
are in this thing that understand what
we're doing and appreciate that those
are the most fun people to hang out with
because you never have to think about
them getting upset at you for saying
something or them taking you literally
or seriously or them not even taking you
seriously but calling you want to
pretend that they're taking you
seriously so that they convert you
signal which I've seen before but I've
never seen from anybody funny no it's
never from anybody funny it's always
from these kind of half-assed sort of
half-cooked versions of a comic yeah
it's never been I was telling you know I
I got no conversation with Ari about
whether what the parameters of a joke
were after the whole Kobe Bryant [ __ ]
yeah
and he said something that made me like
[ __ ] stutter step he was like he was
like it you can't say it's not a joke he
kept arguing you can't say it's not a
joke can't say it's not a joke it was a
joke bird it was a joke and I was just
saying to him you know Tom and I had
said that we didn't think it was funny
he wouldn't think was a joke and then I
and then I wrapped my head around I
remember one time I'll I had a dance on
fifth grade and they did it on stage
right and and they were saying you know
just so you know the parents gonna be
all his boys may dance with boys girls
may dance with girls we just want all
the parents to know that we're cool that
make sure everyone's cool with that and
like a little preamble and I say yeah as
long as they're white and and man some
parents got so upset like really humor
and they were you being serious like Oh
guys I'm joking obviously I want a
professional comedian
I don't wanna dancing with girls wanna
dance with boys and and that's what I
start laughing no no no no that kind of
more mad man it's [ __ ] half this
specialist just times I [ __ ] said the
worst things to people parents a weird
man because some of them are super cool
you know and if you get lucky like I
know a really nice group of super cool
parents of like my kids friends and it's
a pleasure yes when we get together it's
fun like I enjoy their company our kids
enjoy each other's company and we have
great times together it's so I feel so
fortunate for the friends that I've
acquired this way you can find cool
people that aren't comics they do exist
oh yeah you know you can get lucky the
problem is people that take themselves
too seriously or people that are under
the iron fists of like office politics
and office behavior and business
behavior those people get they get
consumed because they're there every day
and when you're there you got a [ __ ]
every day you're wearing a tie you got
slippery bottoms to your shoes the whole
thing's nonsense right yeah and you're
you have to speak and behave a certain
way and you can't make jokes about
anything and sometimes you're working
with girls and you're working with guys
and everybody's flirting with each other
there's all this crazy office politics
as people are trying to move up the
ladder and why they're trying to move up
the ladder they have to make sure they
don't say anything that's gonna sabotage
their career just trying to be funny or
just you know getting a little out of
hand at the company Christmas party
couple cocktails in you and ruining your
career like these people are always on
the at they're always suppressed so when
they're around someone who's not who
just cuts loose like now no you stay in
line now no jokes but they but looking
at you though they could have thought
you were serious oh that's where it's
dangerous cuz they might not be able to
switch gears well look sometimes people
if they knew you were gonna joke around
about something they'd be fine but then
you say something like dad oh my god is
he serious I have to stand up and
denounce racism now yeah yeah this those
man that's the craziest part about I
have it especially I've gone through I'm
weren't my daughter oldest daughters in
tenth grade my youngest is in eighth and
goes formative that K through five those
that that's the fun run of being a
parent and fun cuz you meet a lot of
parents that you don't know yeah and you
say [ __ ] and you find out she I remember
one time we were to drop off and we
found out we got an email about some
what people call it and the mom sent it
from her work account and it was a
[ __ ] porn star and we were like well
I'm wearing drop off me a couple dads
look at watching a [ __ ] being like take
a look at this yeah that's one thing
it's tough to switch gears from with a
guy or a girl if you're a porn star oh
you only want to go legit
it's a tough it's a tough road it's two
men for whatever reason it's weird it's
like if you accidentally did porn but
when you clearly like Kim Kardashian it
hasn't hurt her at all not if she
essentially did porn and everybody's
like yeah but there was no studio
attached it was really independent she's
like she's like the clerks of porn yeah
and then this idea that somehow another
imagine we got online like what happened
how do you get this is a negotiation
process like but when you see like a
mainstream porn star that's been in like
a tons of movies that very rarely do
they make a jump and then just do
regular move like Traci Lords is a bit
of an example of an exception yeah but
she ate some stuff she did a John Waters
movie yeah she did some stuff Kim
Kardashian's porn one even that good how
dare you it wasn't you didn't see her
tits really you never saw her [ __ ] mmm
like it just was like her sucking
his dick that's good enough I don't
think you should ask for too much more
time on she did one movie was better
it's like her first set you know like
you realized like you got out of the
gate too strong you didn't have a good
closer
she's not like you know it's not a
world-class professional I watch Paris
Hilton's porn I was like I would [ __ ]
her with the herpes allegedly allegedly
Wow just catch run a good day right
[Laughter]
that's what this when you saw [ __ ]
Florida all those kids going [ __ ]
those are people that would raw dog it
with herpes and not tell you about me
this is about me this is my vacation I'm
in this other group chat and these these
comics are like these kids are so stupid
how could it be so irresponsible this
and that and I just type in all caps
they want to [ __ ] they don't care they
want to [ __ ] and they're drunk in Mexico
like get out of here you know they want
to [ __ ] where they're in Florida on
spring break a little bit me they're in
Cancun or they're in you know there's
people in Texas there was this thing
about these Texas kids and they were
they were piled onto this this area
together it's like this I don't know we
look like some outdoor party area but
they were just stacked in there like
sardines and people like holy [ __ ] like
yeah yeah you you didn't you didn't
raise your kids right even if you did if
you they're hanging around with other
kids they're fuck-ups they're gonna [ __ ]
up we all did that I was involved in a
lot of really stupid [ __ ] because I was
around some kids that were sketchy when
I was a kid you know especially when I
lived in Jamaica Plain Jamaica Plain was
like this this area that we only lived
there for about maybe less than two
years it was like a year and a half and
it was like an urban section of Boston
that since been gentrified apparently
apparently is nice now the back then it
was sketchy it was like all kinds of
like everyone Irish kids Italian kids
black kids Puerto Rican kids but no one
was getting good parenting everyone's
parents smoked people were drunk like
their chaos people they were like it was
weird there were wild people like the
whole block was filled with wild people
they were
bad people there wasn't like a crime
infested dangerous neighborhood who was
sketchy and everyone was a mess everyone
on my block my next-door neighbor we've
talked about this before they were a
punk-rock band called death in the
shopping mall and they used to play
downstairs in the basement and so they
have these thick layers of carpet set up
in the basement so they had carpet all
over the door carpet all of the ceiling
many many many many many layers and
these guys would [ __ ] could go off and
they're playing guitar and [ __ ]
screaming and I was I guess I was 11 no
13 yeah I was 13 years old because it
was middle it was middle school right
before I went to high school I was 13
years old and I was like fascinated
because I was just becoming a teenager
and living next door to these [ __ ]
savages these savages they just were
playing crazy [ __ ] loud music and you
didn't see punk rock people a lot back
then I remember where there was a kid at
the bus stop on dale mabry and he had a
punk rock haircut every morning gar
driving to school head will look at him
like he's a mohawk his mom let him have
a mohawk well I went from San Francisco
to Gainesville Florida which was a
college town went to Gainesville yeah I
was in Gainesville Florida when I was 11
to 13 you and River Phoenix so we lived
there for a little bit and that was like
just kind of college people and in the
apartments we lived in just regular
folks
it was nothing crazy you didn't really
see too much craziness and father as far
as crime or sketchy folks everyone was
pretty normal different races different
backgrounds but you know just people
apartment life you know yeah
but the hell we moved to Boston man
those kids were wild they'd break into
[ __ ] warehouse buildings and they
were in this day everyone knew how to
steal a car they're like 13 they were
all smoking everyone was smoking like I
immediately went into this crazy
environment of whoa whoa whoa whoa I was
like my dog Marshall and like a room
full of like rabid German Shepherds I
was like hey guys can we talk this out
I'm from an apartment complex I'm not
used to like semi-urban kids
that's an interesting transition as a
young child it was rough man
it was rough when I was 10 I moved to a
neighborhood where was very aggressive
Sam same sort of situation yeah we lived
in it we lived in a real white-trash
neighborhood but my dad kind of
sheltered me a little bit and then it
moved in with like and there was all
boys like they're all like a little
older than me and I remember I learned
the word [ __ ] real quick the first
thing I learned that and how to hold an
ice cube in my [ __ ] really important
things to have it I remember coming home
and being like to my sister a [ __ ]
member yeah you can you can certainly
get ruined by bad kids and no one knows
that more than dads like dad see you
hanging around with sketchy kids I get
hey I don't like you hanging around with
that [ __ ] guy like dad see where that
stuff goes cuz sketchy boys commit
murder you know I'm saying like a
sketchy boys joined gangs sketchy boys
robbed cars and kill people drunk
driving and set fires to warehouses
that's what sketchy boys do sketchy boys
can get you locked up like we did a lot
of sketchy [ __ ] when I was 13 years old
and I remember thinking like wow these
guys been doing this their whole life
and they're 13 I mean well I just sort
of stumbled I just want to be someone's
friend you know I might [ __ ] this that
that's one I took up fishing I really
got into fish the [ __ ] away from these
kids I didn't have I didn't have your
brain I kind of just picked up with them
every time man I did not feel protected
when I was young and it's one of the
reasons why I value community today when
I was young I felt like really
disconnected my parents split up and
then my mom moved in with my stepdad and
he's a great guy and everything like
that and we but we moved around a lot so
I was never around kids that I knew for
any long period of time and I never felt
like I was safe because I remember that
kids would always start fights like boys
have you moved in a new neighborhood
boys always want to start fights
especially if girls think you're cute
girls think you're cute boys want to
[ __ ] you up
I mean and then when I was 13 I was like
I just gotta get the [ __ ] away from
these kids and I found this lake that
was near me I really got into fishing it
was called that Jamaica pond I did you
make a plate and they would stock it
with trout and there was bass in there
all kinds of fish man you can fish there
although and I met this whole community
of people fish they're mostly like older
folks they would fish there and but you
learn about fishing I start fished like
all the time and all is hot
that's you know that speaks a lot to who
you are because that's not who I am
like was dove in when I remember I
remember being like totally anti pot and
then my buddy came in is like you want
to get high and I was like okay I'm in
and we got high on it on Sal's dock well
I had friends like that too
there was a friend named Victor browse
key I'll never forget he was the most
criminal out of all of our friends and
he was selling weed when we were 13 deal
with salad weed at 13 you just call him
he had the weed and he was just like a
dude that like it seen some [ __ ] like
even 13 wasn't mean or anything like
that was a nice guy below he just come
on like what's up man everything cool
you guys cool yeah that [ __ ]
confidence I never been that guy that's
been cool at a party like you're better
off you better off that guy just said
doesn't he's gonna Sun is aware does
that no one should be confident you're
you're a jelly bag made out of [ __ ]
human skin covering these brittle bones
and there's no roof over your head
you're in on a planet and there's no
there's no roof to the planet so it's
just exposed to the universe and it's a
shooting gallery of asteroids out there
and the only thing that protects us is
the thin layer of gas above our heads
you shouldn't be confident exactly how
you are you should be exactly how you
are you just need better methods of
coping than alcohol but the way you are
is a good way to be it's not that
confident thing is not good yeah it's
it's good if you have specific goals
like if you want to be a fighter you
kind of have to be confident but then
like do you know overshot Evans's of
course yeah former light heavyweight
champion awesome guy he's a totally
different human I was crazy I had him on
my podcast and now that he's retired
like one when he was a fighter like you
have to kind of be mean you have to kind
of be a specific part your dog he was a
Beach dude well
I think you think in a rampage you
racist no wait I know you shot Evans I
know yeah what's the rampage you're
right you're right you definitely right
I'm so sorry
listen I'm racist I'm so sorry they just
had a great fight that's why those two
are connected because there were both
coaches of the Ultimate Fighter in the
peak of its popularity yeah and there's
one of the most heated exchanges ever is
them standing like an inch away from
each other saying call me a [ __ ] and I
was like you a [ __ ] I remember that and
they were going back and forth to each
other I'm like oh my god these guys are
gonna throw down on TV it was very very
tense and Rashad won that fight but I'm
like you kind of have to be confident to
be that guy back then you know to be a
light heavyweight champion to be a guy
who knocks out Chuck Liddell with one
punch you have to be that but what
you're not doing that anymore
now we're shots like this real spiritual
guy he's a vegan he he does psychedelics
and he's really intelligent like really
it was a pleasure to sit down and talk
to him because you realize you see the
metamorphosis the the evolution and
maturity as a man he's like a different
person now he's abandoned his old his
own skin his old skin I should say and
become a new person like a very
different new person like a really
peaceful really friendly really nice guy
he was always a great guy but he's like
more at ease now I think that's what
when you said when you were talking
about me backed into a persona of boos
and whatnot I don't know if is that as
much but like I had a conversation with
Ali Wong she said you tore a lot and I
said yeah I was in my head I'm yeah it's
this weird thing about like I got a I
got a work like that when the special
came out that was so on an earth thing
to not to any press to do no Cup st.
Patty's Day do you know I had that huge
st. Patty's Day thing planned and store
call estate the work show I had all this
press like all these marketing ideas and
then it just was like hey the world's
stopping and it took a couple days of
like depression of just like going like
man what I'm gonna do about this special
I got to promote it I got to get out
there and then I think it was
perspective where I was walking to the
garage one night and I was just you know
angst I go I should make a video to Matt
let everyone know my specials on Netflix
i you know in my head and then I went
hold on man there's a lot going on in
this world my space will be
wash is not the most important thing
also I don't think you have to do much I
mean I think having a few conversations
like this you're looking for [ __ ] to do
right yeah yeah they're throttling down
the internet that's what they're really
worried about they're worried about the
infrastructure there they're really
worried about the power grid they're
really worried about internet like
they're already started the throttle
Internet because so many people are
simultaneously streaming you got to
think of how many people are home right
now and how many people when you leave
them home just watch Netflix we watch I
watched especially with my girl at my
daughter's last night just imagine oh oh
no they saw your bits they saw I do not
know the bits before they didn't know it
oh I don't want to say anything but the
one about her having her period oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah I see what ruff was out
she was like poor girl blew out her
[ __ ] dad
the one they reacted to yeah they had me
put my dick on the ass shoulder there
was a lot of them that there were they
were touching go but we what we've just
watched it like quickly flip through it
and then um and then watch big cats big
cat or cat King what is that holy [ __ ]
Joe what is it this is talk about faux
confidence it's a it's on Netflix and it
might be the most amazing show I've ever
seen it's about people who own big cats
like tigers and but the whole thing is
about about petting Cubs cub petting no
no so these guys make a living off cobb
petting so they bring the Cubs around
everyone's car and then what happens is
the Cubs grow up and then they end up
with big [ __ ] cats right and it is I
won't talk to you about it I'll let you
watch it and enjoy it with someone who's
like once you've seen it there's no
reason for me to tell you about it and
even if you treat your cat really really
well you got them in a cage the cat does
not want to be in a [ __ ] cage no [ __ ]
they don't want to be in a CodeRed
someone ripped off Brenda's arm it is
someone ripped off someone's arm Joe you
got to watch it it is it's a hundred and
eighty-seven cats on us Oklahoma
property oh my god I'm gonna save it for
when you watch it and then we can rip
someone's arm off she went back to work
seven days my god no [ __ ] arm so she
now she has a stump little stuck oh my
god still working with Big Easy that is
so crazy
you imagine if they just started eating
part of you and you're like I still got
in a leg I get this part of my foot
the one guy found a job off Craigslist
feels like I'd never seen anything like
this [ __ ] it if you had a job like that
people are gonna sign up like no matter
what it is oh you've got a job to go out
and castrate wolves there's gonna be
guys who like I think I can do it well
oh by the way we haven't even gotten to
the [ __ ] crit this is not even the
crazy part when you get into these guys
lifestyles this guy married one the
first of always get I look gay married
one dude and then they brought in
another dude they have a throuple that's
not the
one the crazy ones a guy that lives in
South Carolina that's got [ __ ] nine
wives who he grooms so this is what like
look everyone my special hey big boys on
Netflix but [ __ ] watch this show
first wow that's strong praise it is
Tiger King I'm writing that down I put
it on my phone me and the girls me the
girls watched hey big boy and we [ __ ]
it was funny we giggled we've talked
through whatever
let the at the end credits I put like
all the stuff his from they put Iowa's
period party cake I put the I put in the
credits I put like her test my dad
howling like an owl and and then big
cats comes along big king what's a call
tiger king tiger king that it and with
in 15 seconds George and I are like
alright everyone's up where we found our
show it's [ __ ] good it's good there's
something about people and giant crazy
animals people that want to keep those
animals as pets like there's this
Russian dude I think who has a polar
bear and he swims at the polar bear have
you ever seen it no no swimming pool
with a polar bear he's like hanging out
with a thing cuddling with it I was like
what in the [ __ ] are you doing but you
don't identify with that a little bit
cuz I do I definitely do as a I do but
big dogs but I think it's cool you know
to watch cuz it's not killing him you
know it's like look at it it's hugging
him it's kissing him until it's not well
I think if you can bears I think are a
different animal because if you keep
bears really well-fed they don't they're
not just predators they're omnivores
right so if you keep bears really
well-fed they're probably pretty chill
and I wonder if bears are like people
like I think if you feed people only
vegetables I really believe this they
probably get less aggressive because I
think your body probably doesn't think
you need to be chasing things and
killing things because you're not eating
animal protein so everybody's like oh we
could just relax and stroll just pick
berries and eat grasses and stuff you
know what I think if you did the same
thing to a bear maybe if you just gave
the bay like apple pies and blueberry
cool yeah
bro he's so big I would love I mean like
here's the problem is I would love one
yeah I don't think you're allowed to
have one for a real good reason cuz
there's a lot of people that should have
[ __ ] dogs man you've seen bad dogs
and people have bad dogs I there's a lot
of you Lucian to have dog special in LA
yeah well there's a lot of people that
like don't they don't train their dogs
Wow and their dogs are like really
aggressive and they they jump up on
people you know imaginative as a bear
that did that just a responsibility look
at the length of its neck it's so crazy
they have such long necks but the just
what it is it's it's you know the the
animal that it is it seems ridiculous
you should be able to have that in your
backyard like that's a polar bear know
where that guy lives where's that say oh
it's gotta be Ohio one of those cities
one guy who shot himself and let all the
animals out yeah they talked about that
on the [ __ ] thing that's part of the
reason that it's illegal to have a
[ __ ] big head low I hope this is that
guy I'm in Ohio and race I would I like
those savannah cats kind
Anthony ku Mia has bangles Yassir Vols
yeah like those isn't that what they're
called serve all cats yeah those are
apparently never really tame they never
really tame our dogs though well there's
I think maybe was John Jones I think
John Jones has a couple of them but he
was feeding them like it was either John
Jones or someone else who had them I
know John has some big cat you don't
want goes to the Darklands can you out
pardon me I just go party with Jon Jones
Jon Daly you'd have one episode you'd
call me up look I quit I quit my show
called Network but yeah so he was
feeding it chicken bones I'm not sure if
it was Jon or someone else but it's
crazy cuz the cat starts making these
crazy noises like while he's like giving
it whoever the guy was it was giving him
the chicken bones while he's giving this
cat these bones the cat is getting
really angry like really scary like you
might just jump on you and bite you like
primal [ __ ] yeah they're not a regular
like if you give a regular cat a chicken
bone they'll be pumped but they're not
gonna go yeah crazy cat noises this
thing was making I was like what see if
you could find serval cat growling while
eating like viral and tik-tok death oh
okay all the time they feed it every day
I've seen I've seen our cat catch rats
oh wow thank you usually I mean I put it
on Instagram a bunch but little cats
rats bring them into the house and then
let the rat go
which is exactly what I want this cat
for and you to watch it on a rat is
[ __ ] fascinating its built-in Brooke
it's like you can't get that out of that
cat's brain ever no built in that's
built into the system yeah that's that
comes no matter what the cat's life is
like if you could have a little bait I
had a ragdoll cat and she was just
fluffy little ball of fur just just
flopped her back and get pet all the
time and she was that's all she was
interested in until she saw a bird and
then it was locked in OH
locked in and she'd make these annoying
noises yeah I have a bit about it in my
act
oh wait I think I special I had the
whole bit about vegan cats because some
lady was mean to me and I went to her
page and I looked up hashtag vegan cat I
was like holy [ __ ] this is the thing and
then I started going down this rabbit
hole of people with animals and cats in
particular how cats are the they're the
strangest animal that we keep as pets
and I have two of them I love cats
they're sweet my dog my oldest daughter
hasn't now mm-hmm it's my middle
daughter is allergic but when I'm around
them I love them I love them but you got
to do weird [ __ ] with them first of all
you had to castrate the male's you got
to fix them all like my dog Marshall
he's not fixed he's fine there's nothing
wrong with him he's not gonna get laid
he's around me all the time and it does
[ __ ] with their energy and it's
irresponsible to have dogs or testicles
and just have them have a bunch of
babies unwanted babies you're right
absolutely but the idea that that's the
only way it has to be that he said the
dog has to either be fixed or you are
you're irresponsible in the dogs gonna
[ __ ] a lot and make babies no you can be
a responsible dog owner
and the dog is not fixed and dog is more
energy like you police dogs done they
were fixed it's four reasons because
they're fixed they stopped producing
testosterone there's a lot of problems
with we got our dog priscilla fixed at a
young age two bull mastiff and we found
out later that when you get a dog fixed
a bull mastiff fixed to young heads up
to any ball mastiff owners it can [ __ ]
with their joints yeah maturity yes you
have to reach physical maturity yeah
your potty needs the hormones that it
was born with i mean this is the whole
idea behind you know like being a young
healthy dog and then if you trim the
dogs balls you're changing what the dog
is and you can do that my point was you
can do that with dogs or you cannot do
that with dogs like you can have dogs
that have their testicles but with cats
you have to do it if you have a male cat
they're all fixed or they will piss all
over your [ __ ] house dude it's nasty
i had a male cat that was a feral cat
that i've raised and I had to corral him
in the bathroom
in order to trap him and bring him to
the veterinarian to fix him while his
corralling him he pissed on the wall he
lifted up his tail and pissed all over
the walls like dude what the [ __ ] and I
had I threw a towel or a bathrobe or
something over him and I scooped him up
and I fought with this cat fought with
him and stuffed him into a laundry
basket and took him to get fixed you
have to get him fixed man
fighting a cat is [ __ ] when you
showed you just how weak you are
he's so little - he wasn't a big cat and
at the time he wasn't even a year old
you know because I was getting him fixed
so I think you get him fixed like seven
eight nine months something like that
she was ready to [ __ ] me up man it was
hard I saw I had to corral him get him
into this [ __ ] launch basket bring
him to dr. Craig was my veterinarian in
Encino before he passed rest in peace he
was a great guy and then when I was
bringing him - he's in there are you
guys gonna be able to get him out you
want me to stay and they're like no I
think we're gonna be able to handle it
and then afterwards I came by to pick up
counties like what - feral cat you'll
only say yes - Rick getting some kid one
time I was like hey can you help me get
a cat my cat out of the tree and I was
like yeah sure
one time and then you fight a cat a tree
[ __ ] can't do that cats in a tree man
first of all without a ladder you might
fall yeah and even with a lot of you
might fall they might jump on you and
bite you and you might freak out and
spaz like a cat is freaked out for its
life up in a tree and doesn't know how
to get down you know they might they
might [ __ ] they might cut you sued
and they once they hook on to you they
hook onto you and they just start
[ __ ] trying to gut you yeah my cat
that was feral he was a he was a trip I
would never have a feral cat again but I
had to like a crazy connection with him
because he was you know he was a well
look a legit wild cat like when I first
got him I had to lock myself in a
bedroom and hang out with him for a few
days just just read books and had a
litter box and brought food in there so
just me and him hanging out together
because he was really little yeah but
when I would pet him he'd be fine he
would purr like really loud it would be
fine but as soon as I put him down he
hiss at me and run away and trying to
climb up the the the curtains he went
crazy so I had a spare bedroom in this
house I was living in Encino and I just
set the bedroom up I set it up for just
me and the cat I'm like all right dude
we're gonna get to know each other these
are kind of shitty things you do when
you're 27 I'm just gonna [ __ ] live
with this cat for a while is me in this
cat are gonna hang out so just read
books for two days locked in this
bedroom with this [ __ ] wild cat and
he would calm down for a little bit let
me purr let me pet him and he would purr
and I'd let him go and he'd hissing me
and run away this went on for two
[ __ ] days and then finally by the end
of two days he was pre chill but then in
two days like this guy just seems to pet
me and give me food you know so I could
always come up to him and pet him
I could always but no one else could no
one none of my friends no one could come
over and pet that cat just me I was the
only one he had an agreement with he was
super cool with other cats like when I
brought other cats and like I kept a
stay with him for two days then I
introduced him to my other cat spaz spaz
was the fluff dog cat and then they got
along instantly like yeah he was like
cats I can trust cats and she's like I
don't know any other cat something great
it's like trains planes and automobiles
one stock candy this other cat that I
had from the time when I was like 25 and
that cat was a [ __ ]
she she didn't like anybody but man she
just was a Conti cat always was a Kunti
cat she she was just a weird cat some
cats are just weird man you know and
then my other cat the fluff ball can't
she [ __ ] loved everybody everybody
that came up were she'd rub on your leg
and you pet her and she'd purr everybody
loved her you could scoop her up and
just start rubbing her belly and she
would purr anybody get anybody could
pick her up but uh cats that there are
their own little thing every one of
them's got their own little personality
ideas you talk to him about his cats at
one point in time I don't know how many
he has now but he had eleven cats like a
two-bedroom apartment and I was like
that is so insane and they all had
personalities man they all some of them
like he was the only one that could
touch and other ones you know ever they
were real friendly with everybody
cats are uh they're a trip but you have
to fix him that was my point is it dogs
you could have a dog that has balls and
they're great like my dark Marshall he's
great like he not aggressive at all and
he's three he seems like a [ __ ] cool
dog sweetest he's the sweetest but you
can't do that with cats you have to fix
all of them they'll piss all over your
house if you like have you ever seen a
male cat that hasn't been fixed it lives
like on a farm bro they don't even look
the same they're these big heads they're
big pitbull heads really yes yes alley
cats that are that are not fixed or
barnyard cats they're famous for being
like vicious vicious animals they're
different they look different they have
their balls they're thick they have
muscles yeah they have thick heads
I guess I've only seen female cats and
kittens when I think about it like my
wife my wife lived on a her grandmother
has a bar like a big farm and there's
always cats here but I think I'm only
seeing the females and the kittens yeah
you've probably seen females kittens and
fixed males you know see castrated males
they're different they don't pee
everywhere and they're more chill dude
if you see a [ __ ] barnyard cat with
with his balls like those are sketchy
animals I'm no I don't think I remember
that back in the day when you'd be like
aa cat sprayed in my car like that was
that doesn't happen anymore but back in
Florida you just leave your windows down
cat sprayed my car one time and I was
like [ __ ] - smells like [ __ ] well spray
everywhere they spraying your house I
would like I would open up my gym bag my
cat of pissed in my gym bag
oh we had dogs all over [ __ ] I remember
one time I was in the car with my
girlfriend in college and we had a dog
Thelma that pissed all over everything
I was with my little sisters in the back
and this girl leads four and there's
like a brown stain on her back we go hey
what's on the back your shirt it goes
all right it must have spilled soda on
my shirt and my little sister's tan at
the time she goes you drink soda over
your shoulder
she was like huh I think our dog pissed
on you sure smelled it you're like yeah
she pissed on her [ __ ] shirt Wow dogs
will piss in your bed if they're mad you
cats will piss on your bed if they're
mad yeah yeah they'll piss on like
they'll piss on your pillow
oh that I've never been I was never a
cat person I was always a dog person dog
and reptiles I was into reptiles for a
long time
yeah I'm fascinated by animals I love
animals but four companions it's it's
hard to be the dog so if you could go
through with all the dogs you ever owned
right yeah
reboot one genetically and get that
exact same dog back today can't do
Marshall because Marshalls already here
I had a mastiff named Johnny Cash I met
Johnny Cash first time I met you he's
the sweetest dog ever I loved him
he's a sweetheart he just it was real
sad watching him age because at the end
he couldn't walk and I used to have to
pick him up and bring him in the house
to eat and then I would carry him
outside again see if he had to go to the
bathroom but he was at a certain point
his life he he really could only lie
down how old did he get 13 which is very
very very or a master was very old for a
mastiff but it was really sad seeing him
seeing him slip away was a rough you
know yeah it's uh it's there it's such a
short amount of time
it really is 13 years Cilla's nine right
now and I mean it feels like yesterday
that we got her we've got a new puppy to
kind of keep her young yeah his puppy's
a con
oh really so much energy I was going
down on the Li and the other day and the
puppy just jumps on the bed we fought in
this [ __ ] just starts licking her face
I'm okay damn it [ __ ] rude dog
doesn't understand it's please don't you
can't work out in front of this dogs I
got were doing jumping jacks huh oh
really
yeah I jumped a baby at a joke that when
the old set that'll probably be retired
now that we're all for what I do instead
of for eight weeks at least eight weeks
man when I mean I believe it's probably
gonna be several months before you know
easily could be longer it could be you
know maybe they find medication that
even though there's not a vaccine
there's some hope for a few different
kinds of medication one of them is a
malaria drug
I don't can't pronounce the name off the
top my head and there's another one that
shows promise as well and they think
that it might be possible that people
could catch this then you would give
them the medication it would wipe it out
there's also there was some speculation
about Tamiflu but I don't think there's
any conclusive evidence that shows that
Tamiflu helps it but there is some these
anti-malarial medications I think that
they think has promised but what
concerns me is that it seems to be so
different with different people that's
what's weird about this it makes it it's
like what's scary right now for
everybody is the unknown like we're in
the unknown like now we've never been in
this situation before as a culture we're
on lockdown and the whole world scared
of a disease not not in our lifetimes I
mean not since like the Spanish flu and
back then there wasn't as much
transportation there wasn't as much
distribution of information so people
probably weren't as aware as we are now
you know of all the various cases all
around them all the time because you
know we're hearing about cases in Italy
and [ __ ] Australia everywhere we're
hearing about cases all over the planet
I don't think that was the case back
during the Spanish flu days I think it
was probably harder to understand what
was happening right because there you
probably only got the newspaper and the
radio back then and everybody had a
huddle around at a certain time and
those are the Masters of information
whatever they said that was it but now
you get all sorts of conflicting
information from doctors man I've read
doctors that think it's not
and then I've read doctors that were
terrified it's like whoa this is nuts
and then you know you look at I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
what these senators did but there's some
senators they had a behind-closed-doors
meeting about the corona virus and China
and what it could meet the United States
and you know the various impacts and
they went out and sold their stock
immediately dude and then they but the
same time they were talking about how
under control the government had it and
how we're prepared and how it's gonna be
fine and meanwhile they knew they knew
so they had two phases they had a public
face that they're given to us to try to
keep us calm and then they had a private
face which realized that the stock
market was going to take a huge loss and
so they sold everything and made immense
profits based on the information that
they found out from these closed-door
meetings about the corona virus how are
they supposed to is that legal how are
they supposed to handle though out of
life legally what are they supposed to
do confusing I don't know what
constitutes insider trading how does
that work do you understand how that
works like if you have information that
can allow you to make money
well isn't that like what everyone's
trying to do like like what is the point
of playing the stock market if you don't
know things and if you do know things
which you know more because you know the
guy was the president he tells you
something about something they're gonna
do and you're not supposed to trade then
because of that information like all
right okay you know I'm sure there's a
logic to it I'm a [ __ ] don't run it by
me but if that's insider trading well
what is it what the senators do if they
knew that the corona virus is gonna
wreck our economy if they knew that it
was coming down like a [ __ ] storm of
hail that no one could stop if they knew
and then they bailed out and made
immense profits that seems so shady that
seems so shady
that they didn't advise people like
you're supposed to be a leader right if
you're in a position an elected
representative you're supposed to be
acting in the position of a leader and
if your way to lead is tell people one
thing but act in a completely different
direction tell people everything's gonna
be fine but then start selling your
stock at a profit and you don't tell
other people to do it because you're
worried that maybe that information is
going to cause some ripple effect and
it's going to destroy the economy even
before the
Korona virus hits just had a panic and
fear and people gonna act wrong but you
acted in a different way than the way
you were talking you acted like this
[ __ ] was gonna be real you act like
there's gonna be a real problem and then
the question is like how much of a
problem did they think it was gonna be
maybe they dumped their stock they
thought it was gonna be a little problem
would that be okay well but if they
found I was gonna be a huge problem then
it's not well that seems weird to me to
like I don't know what should the rules
be with information in the stock market
the stock market is gross like it's the
whole thing's gross like what are we
basing our economy on this [ __ ]
madness this is it's not but it's not
the way that the 2000 2009 breakdown was
2008 when the stock market crashed it
was based on literal numbers and and
investments this is based no no I would
actually say that one was more real than
this one this is a the stock markets
crashed in a way that you're going like
it's based on I I mean I I know that
it's it's for commercial businesses
their loans gonna come up and it's gonna
be tough for them but at some point
you're like I wish you could just put it
all freeze and go hey let's come back in
like two months let's start where we
were let's make sure everyone's fed like
that's but bird this is the ultimate
real because if it's supposed to be
about confidence and things rising and
falling this is like the ultimate
expression of that there's no confidence
you can't work of course if it doesn't
crash here that it's nonsense
yeah then what's the point cuz there's
times where everything's groovy people
are buying like crazy manufacturing is
up everything's up everybody's happy
consumer satisfaction is up and people
are buying like crazy and there's so
many industries that are happening and
there's so many jobs and unemployment to
the lowest rate it's ever been ever in
the history of people and then all the
sudden it's not anymore or of course
it's got a crash so it's gonna crash
this is the crash this is the big one
this is the big one of our lifetime
maybe the biggest one ever because this
[ __ ] could go on for a long-ass time
this is scary - did you think of all
those people just like who are paycheck
to paycheck
you know with waiting tables or teaching
a spin class or whatever it is
that's where my brain goes is like how
come there's got to be a way to [ __ ]
help people
mmm yeah that does I mean I that's all I
do all day is spend like the other day I
hit at McDonald's I was like say there's
a way to buy a buncha Happy Meals I
could send to a neighborhood you could
do that with certain restaurants you
could support restaurants one of my
favorite restaurants in Vegas gitanos is
in Henderson and they used to be in
Calabasas we just go to him way back in
the day but they're they're doing a lot
of takeout and then they're also raising
money for their employers which is very
nice yeah you know and I think the
store's doing something like that we're
all gonna donate for the waitstaff you
know because the waitstaff is completely
[ __ ] out of luck and they were doing you
know good business down there and so
those folks I'm sure they have bills
like serious [ __ ] bills and it's just
piling up and there's no business you
know I mean they went from having this
great place we can go and you can count
on X amount of money per week to all
sudden gone and no one saw it coming
that's never happened ever you can't
blame them for not being prepared but
you know they're part of our comedy
family man we got a we got to take care
of them particularly at the store we
should set up something for The Improv
to and we should also you know just
figure out a way to you know like find
out who's hurting like who's in trouble
look especially in our community a
comics that we know that people are too
proud
look I know but we don't find them
though because there's a lot of comics
in our community they're like they're
going check - check - you know middles
middle acts yeah at headliners yeah
there's a lot of headliners right
particularly first few year headliners
with you only makin you know X amount of
per week and you know you got to pay
your own flight and all that jazz you're
getting by but you're not killing it and
then you you probably have a [ __ ]
apartment that cost two grand a month or
more you know I mean New York City those
guys the [ __ ] apartments in New York
City are ridiculous they're so expensive
so think of all those comics in New York
City that relied on that system of going
club to club and picking up a little bit
for people don't know a lot of comedians
in New York there's like New York's
probably the most condensed comedy club
community in the country wouldn't you
agree
by far yeah how many clubs you think are
in the
city I say 12 yeah yeah you kind of
danger feels never perform there we did
it
Joey was that was my spot when I lived
in New York it's amazing how like a
comic can think in another comics level
because as soon as you said that my two
clubs I thought of Stan of New York and
Dangerfield Tom countin those but
Dangerfield's is the the weirdest one
because that was the one where they
filmed those HBO specials with Rodney
Dangerfield yeah and it was always empty
it was always empty there was never
anybody there man except prom season
prom season you'd be doing stand-up to
like 17 year old kids and it was madness
it was madness do you ever hear story
bill burr story about getting heckled of
Dangerfield now it's my favorite I'm a
built all this a number of times and I
made him tell it on our podcast my
favorite part view memorabilia is
younger right there's a little more
cleaner a little more like tippier hey
guys so Bill's doing his high-energy
happy act and it's to a prom cow like
prom crowd and a bunch of [ __ ]
bridge-and-tunnel Posse and it's not
getting anything and then got in this
guy in the back goes anything red on
stage is a [ __ ] I didn't have one pull
out I just went [ __ ] God man yeah that
one you gotta be prepared for but yeah I
think about I think about it I the
number one thing this whole thing is
done is made me think how much our waste
[ __ ] I waste so much [ __ ] just food
fruit yeah like fruit bananas going bad
just all Mountain no no I've been eating
them
yeah like it's it's waste and health man
when I heard you tell that podcast and
is so glad to know that you were talking
to me because I heard it is if you're
talking to me I told Bryan Callen I go
you ever do a podcast you think just
talking to you and he goes all the
[ __ ] time I'm never talking to you
Bryan Callen never
he said no he said he goes one time
joven said my name was was and you've
been saying this and I've always like
kind of written you off about it going
like well you know whatever you got to
get off that blood pressure medicine
yeah
the second I heard China's got our
medication I got one month above
literally thought now what am i doing on
blood but what am i doing on blood
pressure medicine why don't I just get
in shape and get healthy and get in
control my weight so I'm not dependent
on a pill to come in and then if I don't
have it I have a stroke you can do a
tube Bert it's not outside of the realm
of possibility when you consider how
well you're doing while you're boozing
as hard as you are yeah I think probably
and you always like fire up for sober
October the first year I was worried I
was like man I don't know how he's gonna
do and some people were actually telling
me like a man he could die I don't like
when guys drink a lot then they stop
drinking it's really bad and apparently
that's what killed Amy Winehouse they
everyone kept telling me that house you
killed Amy Winehouse you know did you
know that bro it's one thing when you
host a podcast and you you have a
[ __ ] thousand of them the people
won't tell you [ __ ] that you haven't
heard before so one of the things that I
people love to tell you is about you
could die if you stop drinking you can
die you told me that and you you said to
me when we were leaving you were like
you gave me a hug in you you don't have
to do this man
no I was like I was flipped out I was
worried because I was like damn it
imagine this is how we killed Bert
imagine like trying to get burnt healthy
like it turns out to kill him Amy
Winehouse style dude I love Amy
Winehouse
oh she was this dancing I will throw on
an album and and listen like rehab or
some of her great songs oceania
authenticity there's like an
authenticity to her voice it's
unmistakable like looseness to her voice
she was wild herb York I used to love
Bjork yeah Bjork is great too man -
she's a totally different way like I had
a like pause like it's a totally
different kya sound but yeah but
authentic yeah yeah it's so sexy man
like Bjork was so hot and just doing her
own thing like electronic music in this
time when it wasn't selling here but it
was like you
here's a song it's so so quiet by björk
no oh it's amazing
did you ever see Bjork [ __ ] up that yes
this person thought they could just get
right in her face with a camera just
because she's famous like with no
permits this is not a great app on you
just show up where a person's just at
the airport with her kid Yorkers with
their kid yeah how do you deal with that
I just I most of the time like if
someone wants to be interviewing me when
at the airport or somewhere where I'm
not you know I'm not expecting it it's
just not smart so that's not I do this
all right the way you have conversations
should be your your thoughts that are
gonna get viewed by millions of people
shouldn't be something that you say when
you have your first cup of coffee and
maybe you're half on an edible coming
off the fly and you're picking up your
luggage and you didn't expect to run TMZ
and they're like what do you think about
the corona virus and you like stop
eating bats you [ __ ] but you're you
know you're there at [ __ ] LAX at 7:30
in the morning getting your bags yeah if
that's that's the problem it's it's just
it's not smart and then there was a
weird thing that happened during the
Roseanne Times and Roseanne was gonna do
the podcast for the first time for the
second time rather and she had that that
crazy controversy and they removed her
from a show and the whole deal dude they
were showing up at places where we
weren't with with cameras they were
showing up at the Comedy Store with
cameras trying to capture
I guess if like oh you got me on camera
I gotta talk to you I guess oh yeah like
what the news is if you watch like local
news it's a bunch of people pointing
cameras at stuff and then loosely
applying journalistic ethics to see like
what they talk about what they don't and
what they feed you over the next
half-hour and they want to be number one
in the ratings because you know like
Channel Seven's right now is kicking our
ass and I just really feel like we got
to get on the scene quicker and it
becomes this
your your invite this is not necessarily
the information there's personalities
and jobs are at risk and that there's so
many factors that are contributing and
like in moving what you listen to and
see in a certain direction it's not the
news it's a news program it's their
interpretation of what they think is the
most important stuff to focus on over
the next X amount of minutes because
life is too [ __ ] nuts yeah we have
access to the whole world you can't
you're gonna break the whole world down
in 60 minutes
it's an editing show right because you
can't show everything there's millions
of things that are fascinating that are
going on right now positive and negative
so they have balance it out you know
what are they gonna do a Calabasas woman
not the hard way
you can't woo the show up puppy peeing
on her now let's get back to murder and
death and [ __ ] thievery I said to
someone I said do you think that this
Verona virus up coverage is based on the
news like saying we're taking back the
news that someone was like no man they
began their asses handed them handed to
them for so long by Trump then this is
where they're making their money back
and then you wonder like wow like I like
Chris Cuomo I like him I actually like
him I like I watch him you get upset
when he got mad that guy about the Fredo
thing I got upset for him I go wish I
was there I'll go don't say that don't
say that don't say that it's not like
then or don't do that I understand this
guy's a dick and you're letting no he
can't be a dick to you but let's relax
it was its provoked though and he was
trying to get out of it like you got you
know it's like it's like doing jujitsu
and you make a terrible mistake and also
in you trapped in someone's triangle
you just got to tap out and you got to
live to fight another day you got caught
don't get your neck [ __ ] up and when
he was trying to like save ego when the
guy called him Fredo that first of all
the guy that caught him frayed is a [ __ ]
because because there's such a [ __ ] move
to do like just just as a passerby they
did it to [ __ ] the George Lopez out
of Hooters one time like they some guy
Lopez who did it someone did it
George George Lopez said something like
build a wall or something in George and
the videotape but they want they want to
go viral that's what they want so they
call from Fredo and they're videotaping
it and they're looking for reaction so
they can get views that's a [ __ ] move
yeah
the Fredo made me giggle it's such a
funny say but to say that that's like
the n-word african-americans dude nobody
owned Fredo stop it was he almost made
it more enjoyable
I was watching more enjoyable so
ridiculous is if you watch Godfather -
you wouldn't be able to think of
anything but Kris promo when you're
watching that scene no I think I call
afraid of when he comes on the TV I say
it like with it with the frit with a
freighter his brother is the Governor of
New York they look strikingly alike well
the big brothers I'm very impressed with
how his brother's responding to this
though with the the I you know I
understand that there was a certain
point time where he wasn't sure whether
or not they could really shut down New
York but you know now the way he's
responding to it that's the way carries
himself he's very he's very well-liked
he's in no-nonsense person like the way
carries himself yeah you know I like and
I don't know if I don't know anything
about his politics I don't know anything
about what he does but you can sort of
at least gather from the way someone
handles a crisis like how they how they
carry themselves you gather whether or
not you can trust them if [ __ ] gets
crazy and he seems to carry himself very
well it's like that's very important for
just the morale of the nation in a weird
way that's why a leader is very
important because when someone's a real
leader and even though there's going to
be people that hate them people that are
pissed at everything they do and that's
always going to be the case to be the
leader of the free world right but if
they can somehow or another shift the
way we feel about ourselves shift the
way we feel about our community like
give you it there's like pep speeches
and a really good presidential address a
really good one just gets into that feel
good spot and brings everybody again and
it really has a tangible effect on
reality it can really
feck reality and that's that's what
people don't understand about why people
get upset about people not being able to
talk well it's a big [ __ ] deal
you know I do people like why are you
joking on Joe Biden cuz it's a big deal
he's in the the biggest [ __ ]
sweepstakes on earth who gets to control
all the thermonuclear weapons and the
entire economy and everything that gets
done inside the United States of America
one guy ready go like what you got to be
able to talk really well you want that
job he's just part of the job it's
inspiring people it's one of things
Obama did better than any of them you
know you could say what you want about
Clinton he had some good speeches too I
think Obama was even better because he
was just measured and intelligent and
articulate and strong there was
something about the way he was talking
that was confidence inspiring whether or
not he was right or not whether or not
he made bad decisions I don't think
anybody can do that [ __ ] job I don't
I think it's a death sentence I think it
is for all of them I think I think they
get in there and it's a tornado of [ __ ]
of things that they have to control
things they have to pay attention to
things they're responsible for hundreds
of difference of [ __ ] pieces in
motion all over the world all these
pieces in motion all these pieces and
you're supposed to be the one guy that
makes the right decisions on all of
those and chooses the right people for
both pandemics and the economy how about
just one do you even understand one yeah
and then international relations on top
of that holy [ __ ] and then you got to go
to North Korea and now we're in China
it's too mean it's too many things to
juggle bro it's madness that's why reg
you know I wonder I wonder if it's where
we're going back is to a Reagan like did
you see Matthew McConaughey's speech no
I did not oh is it good yeah well it's
it's Matthew McConaughey right like we
all we all bought into him in the mid
90s like this is our our dream UNK he's
one of our dream hunks for Sean man he
just sits there and he's just for that
Texas drawl about red lights and green
lights here's a yellow light right now
we're going okay and it just and I get
out I got I get like I got sat up in bed
know it's like I'm gonna [ __ ] work
out man like that's this isn't we can do
this well I think for the people like
you
I who you're gonna be okay financially
it's not as scary it's a different thing
but for the people we're financially
it's kind of affect them greatly there
has to be like real big decisions made
to help those people because this is not
it's not a situation of people not
wanting to work it's a situation of
people not being able to work because of
an invisible enemy that kills your loved
ones like if there's ever a time where
the United States has to come together
this is the time and I think I think
we're capable of doing that and I think
if we do the right thing and we come out
on the other side I think we're going to
be stronger I think we're gonna be
stronger and not in the not dismissing
the losses and the the people that are
gonna badly miss loved ones I'm not I'm
not even trying to diminish that I'm
just trying to say for the people that
that will survive we're gonna understand
what it's like to go through a real
adversity together for the first time in
a long time as a planet not just as the
United States not as Germany not as
Japan not as Iraq know the whole thing
together because it's everywhere and the
whole thing together is a giant problem
for everybody that survives and for
everybody that survives no matter how
bad it gets or how good it gets whether
it morphs and changes or whether it
doesn't the people that survive we have
to learn from this we got to learn we
got to learn in every way and we got to
learn how and I'm learning I'm learning
right now my own personal self like how
I'm shifting how I view the world like
that everything has to go back to me
being able to do shows whenever I want
and do stand-up whenever I want and
travel wherever I want to go and not
worry about killer but everything has to
go back to that because that's what I'm
used to ya know like just you know
history you know how the world works
there's countless examples of
civilizations that no longer exist and
they got wiped out by plague or natural
disasters we are well aware of this but
yet none of it ever registers and we
never think it applies to us we never
think that this is it this is the one
this is the one we got to really pay
attention no [ __ ] you see them
kicking all the people off the beach
from alibi they said Santa Monica the
leg we're close to the beach you [ __ ]
vacation people are down there just Sun
Tanning and hang them out of my girls
wanted to go for a hike yesterday and I
went think all the morons that are out
hiking the thing is that this required
us to act fast and I think the human
race is giant and it's so huge the
number is so spectacular to get all of
us to coordinate together I think it's
like an impossibly long battleship think
of a battleship it's like a hundred
times bigger than a regular battleship
just a battleship you think how fast
that thing turned it's it's gonna be so
slow I never thought about that riding
with them speed boat so you can just
know it's if you're on a battleship that
[ __ ] hard to turn and I think
the human race is like it's an
impossible to imagine battleship it's
like a battleship a hundred thousand
times bigger than any other battleship
it's so big it takes up like 1/10 of the
ocean that's how big this battle and
when that [ __ ] has to turn it's
like
you barely turn bad that's us
and I think this thing required us to
turn we're an it's like an iceberg
there's a giant thing ahead of us
something hit us this change in in a
virus that jumped to human beings and we
have no immunity for it that's what it's
like it's like like we our battleship
does not turn quick enough for this and
we didn't have the proper preparation
for something like this because we
didn't see it even though we knew it was
possible we didn't see it happening to
us
we made some preparations but I don't
know did we ever figure out whether or
not the government actually did stop
this pandemic office and closed down his
pandemic office is that true remember we
were trying to look at that the other
day digging through that was not fun
something was changed I don't know about
closing the thing it's an interpretation
sort of discussion that like I don't
know huh I was trying to dig till I
PolitiFact and all sorts of websites
that like we got it took too long to
find that were a good answer that was
worth sharing so like I don't I haven't
I don't know what did you think though
when you were what did you think when
you read it like what were they
specifically saying definitely there's
different people in place and what I had
one of the things I read along the path
was that there was like a meeting about
possible pandemics with the with a team
of people in an office those people are
no longer there though there might be
people that have replaced them because
of how many people have changed over in
the administration so the people that
are in those places now weren't at the
meeting so they don't they never got
those like notes basically yeah but
that's the same stuff that happened in
9/11 they're like these these were all
warned like it's it's interesting to see
fine hindsight really in action where
you're like I have this for this
comedian this very hilarious comedian
who doesn't do comedy more a woman named
Andy Smith in [ __ ] early February she
sent me a text that I figured she had
postpartum depression I was like oh
she's lost her mind that's too bad she
was really funny she had a kid must be
going through a divorce and
was hey i've been translating these
chinese documents this flu is gonna get
a lot worse than anyone thinks we need
to stay home you need to start spreading
the word you have a podcast like me so
you thought she was
how many weeks goes pulled up right now
she just texted me last night she this
was february 15th she wrote hey I'm home
classes hey it's me again I've been
googling translating the [ __ ] out of
this virus situation for weeks and stop
traveling tell everyone to stop right
now I know I know I come off I I can't
[ __ ] read on glasses here look at
these here boys your yeah try blind I am
the same they'll come the [ __ ] off are
we really gonna stay until they wait
until they tell it to tell us to stay
off the streets that's where we are
today
mmm that will be a little too late right
honestly everyone should just call in
sick Tuesday what are they gonna do suit
up fellas come on over and see if I'm
lying is genius really it's probably the
most American knee protest thing ever
just lazy paid refusal and probably our
last chance to legally shift power back
to the people who forcibly be dragging
us back in SUVs maybe you're already
stay in a safe hillside bunker I hope so
sorry for the downer rant I'm sending
this all the smart people I know four of
you because all my dumb [ __ ] friends
I've no grasp on strategy or intuition
[ __ ] stay home learn to knit learn how
to knit a facemask I wish we could all
stay home and jump the gun save
ourselves and then I wrote on [ __ ]
the day my special drop note on [ __ ]
March a month later I wrote oh [ __ ] you
were right and then she texted me a
bunch of medications to get my bottom
all stood and by the way not to discount
her she was a [ __ ] tits hilarious
comedian why did you stop doing stand-up
shut a baby she oh she's got a major
beef with like Schumer and Nikki Glaser
like legit [ __ ] this chick was a
little she was up to is rough man she
was wrong
but I'd fight hard for one last comic
standing called Adam hunter a [ __ ]
like suck it burn it to the ground just
because she just that's who she is she's
a [ __ ] man he's a nice guy
he's a great guy he's a great guy him
and her got onto it on screen Oh No yeah
but she's wow she's wild man she stole
Jim Jeffries sunglasses like [ __ ]
real [ __ ] wild chick but she sent
that to me I'm like that much month ago
and I just was like oh postpartum she's
crazy
poor girl they they're saying these
senators he's closed-door meetings that
they had this closed-door meeting that
was in January there's kinda beloit
that I follow on Twitter he's the one
who sent it to me and he had a series of
tweets about it documenting it laying it
out and you read it you go oh my god
it's like did they really know or it's
again it goes back to that thing like
what are you supposed to do like are you
allowed to just start talking about that
this is coming like if you're a senator
and you find out about something like
what it what are your responsibilities
did they give you a mandate and what
you're allowed to talk about or not
allowed to talk about like if they sit
you down and have some crazy meeting
where they tell you the sky is falling
what are you allowed to say do they tell
you when you're allowed to say it like
how does that work black Twitter says
that this was a distraction because
there's a comment hitting us oh Jesus
yeah our bus drivers black and he was
like you know what just wanna make life
suck right before the [ __ ] big one
hits how kunti what well Mike you know
what now that I'm thinking about it
might not have been Peter attea that
said that I don't want to tribute this
to him
just in case I'm wrong that said that
people that are around it more often
seem to get sicker it might've been some
I don't want to look right now but let's
just take that away from him but if that
is the case that's all that's so it's so
different than anything else it's weird
with what's weird to me is how some
people apparently nothing happens and
other people just get rekt like we're
talking about the same thing like what
is this thing
I had h1n1 did you really yeah oh I just
figured it out
like a couple days ago
it was the sickest I've ever been in my
[ __ ] life and I was like and I I mean
I mark it down as like I thought I was
gonna die
was that over December one happened a
lot in America or was it mostly overseas
it happened I was talking to drew my
podcast happened around 2009 in December
November December is when we had an
outbreak in America in America my cousin
had it dr. drew is telling me about his
experience and I was like that's so
[ __ ] crazy and I told him like oh the
sickest I've ever been and I recounted
it then I go through my Instagram for my
my facebook photos and I look that's
December 2009 and I go dude I got h1n1
it was I'm telling you when I say I've
never felt like that when you don't get
off your brute you kind of breathing but
you're not getting oxygen to your lungs
and my wife didn't get it my wife didn't
get it my kids didn't get it my mom
didn't get it
Wow I was with all of them and then my
wife and I got on a plane and I drank
and that is what [ __ ] me up I drank
and I got into Mexico and I was
I mean without a doubt the sixth I've
ever been the sickest I mean gasping for
breath could not be comfortable throwing
up chills it was the worst chest
infection I mean I thought it was always
written it off - walking pneumonia and
then we were talking about it and I was
like December 2009 that's exactly what I
[ __ ] got it wow that one had a really
high fatal ization rate in within 40 to
50 year olds yeah
so what's crazy no word fatal ization I
made up I was right fatality rate is
what I should have said but I was
thinking does that you can't even say it
that way it's funny it's funny how
saying something wrong the wrong way
just immediately makes you a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you can say like the most interesting
and complicated [ __ ] ever but then you
said and then like the fatal ization of
it all like what what the [ __ ] did you
say
fatal ization you fraud it's like when
you used you ever use a a saying wrong I
went I pitched I pissed a movie in
Hollywood and I use salt of the earth as
if they were dirty people these are the
real salt of the earth you know the
people you want to stay away from
oh no that's the it's isn't it funny but
that's this is how easy it is for us we
can't understand the wars were fought
over salt they literally fought for war
for wars they fought wars the killer sea
salt yeah for salt salt was so important
salt was everything because salt allowed
you to preserve food you could take fish
and meat and all these different things
you can cover them in salt and the salt
prevents growth of bacteria so you can
keep things even at room temperature far
longer covered in salt than you can if
they're out exposed to the air for real
100% yeah so the salt of the earth was
like a incredibly valuable thing well we
really used that wrong that wasn't that
long ago man people were having [ __ ]
wars over salt this this whole situation
is a has forced you to think much more
globally and and transcendentally
transcendentally but like down those two
words go together ever but like like you
you look like a double verb you look at
that I want my daughters were watching
some movie about the Great Depression
yesterday and I was like oh that seems
kind of real yeah now it does if the
world seemed like [ __ ] that'll never
happen to us because it would have never
happened to us economically as [ __ ] up
as the economy is it dips and then it
comes back because the same amount of
people need the same amount of [ __ ]
right so you got to make stuff and it
just comes back yeah right same amount
of people are willing to work see my
people healthy same amount of physical
resources required to make that [ __ ]
okay let's figure it out how to make
this [ __ ] again and then people make the
[ __ ] and they sell the [ __ ] and things
keep moving this is different this is
more more disturbing than anything we've
ever seen because it's something that
nobody suspected and all the the
consequences of a global pandemic nobody
ever thought oh no the whole world would
have to stay home and no one would ever
work no one thought never never in a
million no one thought that no one wrote
a script about that but then some people
have to work right like super market
people and healthcare people and firemen
other people didn't have to work the
only okay so we're just kind of what
kind of putting a bandaid on it but it's
all going to keep getting out right it's
gonna keep getting out if they get it
like if they get it in there in contact
with people all the time they're gonna
be the bridge between people and the
disease because not everybody can just
stay home and they it's almost like we'd
have to go door-to-door with people with
[ __ ] hazmat suits on delivering food
stay in your house everyone I stay in
their house for two weeks like it's
gonna get to a point where if it keeps
coming back like do they keep
instituting stiffer instill measures
like it's just started right and already
we're we can't have public gatherings
more than ten people can't have can't go
to a restaurant you can't do a stand-up
show you can't go to the movies so all
those things are done gyms are closed
all these things are closed
this has never happened before and
everybody just stays home well if what
if that doesn't work what do they keep
ramping it up you know what if like five
months later they realize well what
we've done is instead of like letting
this disease blow through everybody it's
gonna blow through quickly now it's like
slowly trickled into everybody it's
gonna affect still affects the same
amount of people still infects the same
amount of people that mean they don't
know whether or not that could possibly
happen they're hoping that it wouldn't
but it could flare up again that was
that's another piece of concern they're
worried it could flare up again that's
one of the things that's crazy is yeah
uncertainty yes exactly that's the
number one thing because we all want to
pretend that all this [ __ ] makes sense
even though we're temporary life forms
[ __ ] started even though even though
the star that powers the solar system
itself has a finite lifespan and things
have changed so much even though all
those things exist we still want to
pretend that the world is going to be
the way it is right now forever
I think this is not good for us and that
people are gonna die and people are
gonna get sick but it might be the
survivors of it might experience a shift
in the understanding of what it is to be
alive what it is to be a person what
this life is this life is not it's not
about fame or money or
or getting your point to be the one that
gets accepted by everybody or you know
arguing with the left or arguing with
the right it's not that it's life is
people hanging out with each other and
stayin alive that's what it is have you
interacted with people like we were out
putting the fence up in our front yard
some people walk down the street it's
kind of cool
they're waving to each other yeah people
are saying hi people are appreciating
each other a little bit more you're
scared guy said to me the other day goes
hey man how you doing I said goodness
how you guys holding up I didn't even
even know the guy I said good eye how
about you guys really cool I went to
like a [ __ ] insane toothache in the
middle of a night the other night right
I had to go to Rite Aid and it was open
and I was so grateful you know you take
it for granted
let's go to Rite Aid and I started
driving there and I go they're probably
not open like we're in the shutdown yeah
I pull up and they're open for young
ladies sitting there with gloves on in a
mask I buy some amber saw and I go I was
like I never said this I go hey thank
you like thank you for being awake in
the middle of a pandemic yeah I'm
working here so that just a toothache
like a [ __ ] toothache people risking
their health that's I hope that we still
feel this when when things start to
clear up and I'm an I'm optimistic I
really do think we're gonna [ __ ]
flatten this curve and things are gonna
go back to normal and everyone's gonna
be safe but I hope that people are still
that way I hope it ways with young kids
it ways with me because I'm a little
older and I feel like I'm I'm allowing
myself to change in a grateful way of
like seeing things and noticing things
that maybe I didn't notice because I
lived in Florida I lived in different
places I hope it happens with kids I
hope kids my kids put their phones down
and want to interact and want to you
know do and be like I had a month on my
[ __ ] two months on my phone I'm out I
want to I want to go ride a bike or
something you know yeah well there's
levels that this can drop this is one
level one level is stay at home you know
another level to this could drop is if
the grid goes down you know there's
things things that we rely on that we
don't even we don't even think twice
about hitting that light switch and
knowing that
that juice would be powering all these
lights and then my refrigerators gonna
stay on and then you know I'm gonna keep
being able to charge my Tesla every
night you assume all that but there's no
guarantee there's no guarantee that this
fragile system is gonna stay in place
particularly if something bad happens
like solar flare like one solar flare
could wipe out our whole grid one big
one can wipe out you know I mean one
asteroid impact one you know one crazy
supervolcano eruption wipe out
everything all of it and then those
things are real they happen all the time
there there are a hundred percent real
there are hundreds entry land we've
documented the history of them and in
the planet Earth [ __ ] thousands we
just don't live that long man
we don't live that long so we forgot we
forgot that all this [ __ ] happened and
we thought that because you know from my
my life from 67 to 2002 there was
nothing nothing like this the things
like this don't happen that's amazing
it's amazing how many people have called
me about guns I do a bit about guns in
this new special and everyone's like hey
man get me your gun guy Texas get
yourself a ranch
thank God we trained with
what's-his-name yeah tarantara tarantara
oh man I know how to use my gun I feel
very confident with my gun yeah it
certainly helps you get some training in
eep eep that's a it's gonna be a big
issue with people shooting people
accidentally what people that don't have
good firearm safety and they haven't
been instructed correctly and they just
caught shoot guns oh yeah I don't know
what the rules are today in terms of
being able to buy a gun when I first
bought a gun there was no rules you just
if you weren't a criminal you could just
get a gun when was this when I first
came here 94 oh really
yeah the rules now are it's a 12 day
waiting period and you have to take a
test test it's pretty easy you take a
test you buy the gun and then they have
to wait indefinitely had a waiting
period don't get me wrong back then but
what I'm saying is there was no
instruction no no there's no instruction
yeah that's what I mean like there was
no you did you didn't have to show your
proficiency or
didn't have to definitely show that you
know you know where the safety is and
you know remove a magazine you didn't
have to show anything I didn't even he
gave me some play bullets like they're
red
he was like mess around with those you
know get comfortable with your gun and I
and they didn't work so I never figured
out I just literally had a gun I didn't
even load it I was like I don't have a
gun I don't know what to do with it and
then Taryn taught me everything hmm and
so that's what the only reason I know
how to do anything with my gun but I
bought two guns didn't know how to
[ __ ] I had a bullet this is a joke in
my special but it's true I put a bullet
in the shotgun and I thought I got the
one that goes but I did in and I didn't
know how to get out I was like I called
my buddy coward I go how do I get a
bullet out of a gun here's like this cow
head live in Florida yeah yeah yeah dude
cowards talk to the gills I would call
Anthony ku Mia first and full you have
another one yeah okay take one more one
more
we're not getting crazy we're having two
drinks like gentleman over a short
period of time yeah
what is it an hour and 36 minutes into
the podcast perfect we halfway spaced it
yes perfect I feel perfect right now
yeah no worries I don't want to send you
off the off to him the wagon you know
man I I had a like the little weird
epiphany about like I want to be with my
kids right now
you know like hanging with them that's
what I'm hoping is good it's gonna come
out of this right for all of us I hope
so man Cheers Joe thank you for doing
this man pleasure I know I'm just
swamped you are I love it
I Love You Man mmm that's a good whiskey
that Buffalo Trace yeah I just love the
fact that this company started out
during the pioneer days this is a
company from the 1700s that's ridiculous
Jesus from the 1700s one company it's
gotta be one of the oldest companies in
the country what's the oldest come how
was I mean I think that [ __ ] was around
like like right when the United States
is being formed
we got Levi's or no that Levi's were the
1840s right I don't know
they were canvas right they used to make
them out of canvas they made them out of
old tents well I think yeah I think the
canvas that they had back then was
probably made out of
- is probably hemp that's why it's so
durable that's what they used for
clothes forever
apparently I've I've had a hemp shirt
what's kind of wack
I always felt your hippie when I was
wearing it sliding doors sliding doors
I'd like to see that transition and Joe
were you smoke weed but don't love
jujitsu and you get into like an oxygen
bar I had a I still have a hemp key from
dot Seuss ara it's [ __ ] great
yeah hemp is it's uh it's a weird fabric
it's it's really really durable like
it's my hemp Keys never ripped look hot
no man the stitching might go eventually
but man cotton jeez after a few years
they give out you know all these dudes
trying to kill you they're yanking on
you and [ __ ] they rip they rip at the
armpits they get bleached a bunch of
times to get a little weaker they start
ripping that half [ __ ] that
thing doesn't rip at all it's an alien
planet hey what's the name of that plant
what's the name of that dude you had the
best [ __ ] this is nine years ago you
talked about a guy who did a kettlebell
workout and I had it on my computer and
I have and I'm Keith Webber is that it
was like a [ __ ] 20 minute kettlebell
cardio workout oh oh my god incredible
it was like heart attack oh yeah yeah
it's and you could do with a 35-pound
kettlebell you hold on to the 35 pound
kettlebell with this thing and doing
[ __ ] dude I'll throw that around a 10
minutes in I'm ready to die that's the
one I've been looking for that come true
I won't let weightlifting is my thing
right now like I want to I want to put
mass on because I don't want my bones to
fall apart mmm so all I do is run all I
do is run in spin class that's it but I
wanted to I want to do I want to put
weight on like one of the lift weights
that's a good move I like the way you're
saying it - you don't want your bones to
fall apart
yeah that's people need to take that if
there was a supplement that you could
take that would actually increase your
bone density you're not popular
supplement would be something that would
be so popular everybody would want to
take some that actually increases your
bone density and it makes you less
vulnerable to breaking your leg if you
fall down that's when [ __ ] goes sideways
is when
sixty-five and you break a hip you break
your femur that's a game changer a
broken bone yeah you want to maintain
muscle mass and the best way to do that
is by picking up heavy things well
during this isolation period though one
of the things you can do especially
because we're assuming this is only
gonna last like a month or two we're
hoping one of the things you can do is
you could do a lot of [ __ ]
calisthenics you know you can do all
kinds like you can do significant
numbers of push-ups and bodyweight
squats and if you have a chin-up bar
just a chin-up bar that you fit inside
the doorway it's perfect just get one of
those get one off of Amazon get the kind
that you screw into the wall so it can't
fall off on you you don't want to die if
you get silly and try to do flips back
and forth you fall on your face there's
no hospitals okay just get a regular
chin up bar just a chin-up bar push-ups
sit-ups doing like like a bunch of
different bodyweight exercises like
pistols and you know like one one-legged
squats and different yoga routines you
could get shredded you know the Herschel
Walker story that he actually got jacked
from doing push-ups and sit-ups and
stuff in between commercials of shows
you would watch no yes dude that's my
brain that's my grain I love I love
nothing more than a punishment challenge
like a punitive like we were doing that
one the road I was like because Marky
Mark and dr. Wahlberg dr. oz did their
push-ups I made a joke video going
there's a [ __ ] push-ups yeah we're
[ __ ] push-ups dude I did [ __ ] 60
of them but why did they do that
Marky Mark is a stud push-ups were
better than dr. Oz's he gets mad if we
call Marky Mark definitely I got nothing
but respect for him I got another burger
that guy he's on the great actor he's on
a campaign right now like he's nothing
but in my newsfeed about what about just
I don't know clear like a PR campaign I
don't know what he's I don't know what
he's well it's probably all about him
you know promoting a movie or something
like that Spenser for hire very [ __ ]
inspirational guy dude his Boogie Nights
is one of the best nights [ __ ] ever
what does that movies ever he's got a
lot of great movies
he'll illegally
a lot of great movies but like as a
human being like when you look at like
his dedication to fitness it's not
bullshitting he really is up at five
o'clock in the morning workout like a
beast every is the real deal yeah he is
like I think if you had pivoted and
Justin acting I think you guys have
probably similar personalities like very
like dedicated I don't know really yeah
I never met him he was had a UFC once
but I was doing commentary and sometimes
in celebrities there I look over try to
catch their eye say hi you know I got a
hug from Jeremy Renner I was very
excited really I never met him he came
over giving big hug I was like dude he
seems like a really cool guy he's really
cool he's really cool
but yeah more Mark Wahlberg's pitch
push-ups looked legit like kind of like
he's a legit stud if you look at his
workouts I mean that guy goes after it
you don't get built like that I don't
care what you're taking you don't get
built like that unless you work hard
yeah there's no magic pill that's all
hard work like whenever someone says oh
yeah they're on testosterone replacement
this that's wonderful I'm sure that
helps it definitely helps but you don't
get built like that in unless you're
working out hard dr. Oz's push-ups are
[ __ ] no more marks looks like tricep
push-ups [ __ ] [ __ ] well the
right way to do a push-up I'm not being
a stickler but legitimately for your own
body dr. oz is actually doing it better
in that he has his elbows closer to his
body and follow me here like your hands
in front of you and this and this is a
good motion for your shoulders yeah a
lot of people think that this is a not a
good motion that this elbow out it's a
different thing and maybe it might be
better to do it the way Mark Wahlberg is
where you're not going up all the way oh
I'm sorry I got them confused dr. oz is
closer to us yes doing it right I got
them confused and he lapped him it his
Polo's was the mark wahlberg was doing
him way better I'm sorry I said it the
wrong way
I really thought that was Mark Wahlberg
in front of us for some reason as dr. Oz
says why did I think that this is strong
weed obviously the guy with the [ __ ]
hat in the gloves is wise Marky Mark -
oh my my push-ups on my Instagram I
looked at these push-ups I was like dr.
oz those aren't real [ __ ] push-ups
they're not neither one of them are
doing
marky-mark do you know that marky-mark
can hang the [ __ ] out probably decided
they're going for numbers and he can't
lose the dr.oz by doing legit push-ups
what dr. oz is doing those [ __ ]
push-ups it's like a strategy here's the
problem with like I love Mark Wahlberg I
love him on this podcast but he's he's
not he's not on the table the way he
would be without cameras oh yeah he's
too brand friendly I want it I want the
hold he's doing great he's doing a
podcast
don't do it I'll talk to you off off air
yeah I'm sure he's awesome man
he really is I was in Boston at Medford
in the Chevallier it's a like a smaller
or like a thing in there what is it it's
a theater it's a it's a feeling you do
can do the Wilbur oh the chevaliers it's
seats more but it's a it's in Matt
friend Medford oh yeah yeah I lived
there for a little bit okay yeah so I
know you I know you've said of talked
about living a Medford and then I got
obsessed and bill [ __ ] sucks about
this because he just shuts you off you
guys dead it's all same talking Boston
look look I'm not walking Robert I'm not
Southie nanami but like on this
different spots emboss I was obsessed I
want I want if someone can online do
this I want to all the Boston comics all
of them even like Dennis Lee it like all
of them one with them I want to put on a
map and I want you to tell me about that
local area because if you do that with
Florida is very simple to wrap your head
around Jim Breuer grew up like lived in
Brooksville at one point if you know
Florida you know Brooksville you know
who moves to Brooksville right so like I
want to don't so tell me [ __ ] it is it
is like borderline retiree that's what I
want for a neighbor
I want a crazy old dude with guns with a
hot young wife I think that what's up
bro I like how you doing it but I want
to know all about Boston and and like
all my all my friends I want to know
about their neighborhoods where they
grew up and how that define them because
I hear Boston and I go was Bill you Dane
Gary Gulman I've never really lived in
Boston Boston I
lived in Newton which is a very nice
community it's outside of Boston which
is a Newton Upper Falls where I lived
which is like the blue-collar but even
the blue-collar part I went back there
just a few years ago it's idyllic it's
beautiful really oh yeah it's so nice I
lived across the street from the Charles
River right across the street from this
big-ass Park the Charles River was back
there and I could hang around and play
in it when I was a kid
Newton was a very very almost it was
suburban but there was also like
elements of rural [ __ ] there was like
rivers and forests and stuff that were
really close by a lot of woods a lot of
trees and woods so where were Matt Damon
and Ben Affleck from I don't know I
don't remember they were from more of an
urban part I mean I like I said I lived
in Jamaica Plain first for like a year
which is like sketchy but Newton wasn't
sketchy at all Newton was nice it was a
good place to grow up it was pretty easy
I mean there's [ __ ] between kids but
there's always bolt everywhere you
[ __ ] everywhere you go you're gonna
have [ __ ] between kids they're all
trying to figure their way through life
but like ultimately there's a pretty
nice place to live and also man I think
there's a [ __ ] giant benefit to
growing up where it gets cold in the
winter
I really do I never had my kids getting
screwed getting I think they're I think
you're getting screwed if you live in a
place where it doesn't get cold why cuz
it builds character it also teaches you
about weather in nature like there's a
reality of the consequences of going out
when it's cold you could die out there
there's a consequence of driving on the
road where you can't see where you're
going because the road doesn't exist
anymore because there's so much snow
yeah that's real that can happen Oh
didn't happen to me until I was like 29
30 first time ever drove in snow yeah
but there's a but there's a something to
be said for a it is cool to be a
grown-up and see snow for the first time
oh I'm sure it's like probably
appreciate it more than I did
oh I see snow I get so excited when
snows well I had it till I was seven and
then I had it again when I was 13 so all
those years I lived in California
Florida obviously I never saw snow it's
awesome know one time when I was in San
Francisco I remember I was like wow this
is interesting it's like one of my
strongest memories from San Francisco
it's snowed in a little bit of snow
snowed in Tampa in like 1978-1979 yeah I
remember it so [ __ ] vividly it shuts
[ __ ] down but it also you get pays you
back with character you develop
character my favorite people almost to a
person in terms of like their attitude
about things are all East Coast people
yeah all my favorite people so many of
them are so many of our cold-weather
people so many of them I mean it's a few
that I'm really close with that are la
people that born raised here and it
sound like I like them less it's just
that the numbers of people that are
interesting that I never saying there's
less bumps on them when they grew up in
LA you're like yeah so you grew up in
Santa Monica
well I remember Northridge oh I bet you
do I was I was hanging out on the top of
I had a like when I lived in Newton we
lived on this really steep street and
there was a part of like above my
parents bedroom or you could stand on
the roof so you could go out to the back
you climb up a ladder you can stand on
the roof and me and my friend J Jewett
were no I'm sorry was John Jewett Jays
brother Jay was my friend too
yeah John and I were on the roof and we
were cuz Jon's date my sister and we
were watching cars slide down this
frozen Street and slamming the curbs
every car that went down the street was
[ __ ] because they didn't know that was
it was all black ice the whole street
was black guys and we sat on the roof
and there was not a goddamn thing we
could do wait and how many black guys
no not black guys black black guys just
watching white people cream and I'm like
holy got so much better it got so much
better black guys winter weather black
ice I'm sorry
I probably we've had a lot of weed and
pot and
alcohol I probably work so much better
before watching a bunch of black guys
like it's a slam dunk contest like oh my
car is just bouncing off the curb and so
we called the cops and we told them hey
there's all these cars like two cars in
a row have come down this hill and
they're bouncing off the curbs and so
the cops came down the hill and they
[ __ ] bounced off the curbs these
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and we're bounce off these curves like
this [ __ ] idiot did you not listen we
called you man you got the pho you like
call Domino's they came the same way
everybody else did and the same thing
happening like we know better we know
better we're gonna come down like show
you home I was how to drive I really
believe that growing up like that is
good for you I think spending my high
school years in Massachusetts was really
important it's really important to
shovel snow like that was one of the
ways we made money like you get pumped
when it snowed out because you could
charge people so you'd go to this lady's
house and you know you knew she couldn't
shovel this [ __ ] long ass driveway
and you make a negotiation like when I'm
looking at it I'll try to figure out
like I'm trying to do my math math is
always terrible valuable trade yeah like
14 I'm trying to figure out how long
it's gonna take to dig up two feet of
snow from 40 feet of driveway hmm price
point on that some people we're great
some people were really generous they
even give you a tip you know they pay
you like you maybe $100 to do a whole
long-ass driveway but bro it would take
you all day you know when someone has
one of these [ __ ] that goes up
to their house and you got a and it's
like two feet of snow you gotta do you
don't even realize how much work that is
dude I would come home wrecked just rat
dude we were we were at a year at 7,000
feet in [ __ ] Idaho right and I low on
oxygen
I'm we've been riding snowmobiles
drinking beers all the way up to this
yurt and I get there in the whole
[ __ ] deck is covered and there's a
fire pit
I'm so excited as a Florida kid I go I'm
gonna shovel the deck and everyone's
like hey man you got a [ __ ] heart
attack then I go I don't know I'm good
I'm good I'm good I've been so excited
about shoveling snow my whole life right
I've never done it it sucks
within I gave it to my buddy John Sayles
like oh you got a finish man I can't do
this [ __ ] I was like I'm Florida kid man
I gotta put on my flip-flops dude do you
know how many old ladies hurt themselves
trying to shovel their way out of their
house every year in cold climates when
they don't have someone like a support
system like a Sun or some come visit
them and help them a lot of guys that I
know that East Coast guys that live in
the neighborhood of their family or
anywhere near their family like it's
almost like understood when it snows out
you go over to your mother-in-law's
house and you dig her out cuz she start
that's real [ __ ] man yeah I have to that
i think that it's dangerous and it's
definitely an added [ __ ] of life where
you like you come to california like
thank god there's no snow and that's how
I was when I first moved here my thank
god there's no snow but part of me is
like man I learned from that snow I
learned a lot of [ __ ] dude that taught
me a lot about perseverance because I
used to deliver newspaper so I drove
every day I drove every [ __ ] day
every day 365 days a year I was driving
for years because it was the best way to
not have a job while you have a job yeah
the job was I just had to go somewhere
and get the newspapers and then follow
the route and throw them out the window
but while I'm doing that no one's
looking over my shoulder no one's
telling me what to do and it's not the
worst pay in the world it was pretty
good pay Thrifty Nickel I used a little
bit of Thrifty Nickel of Tallahassee oh
yeah Oh Sean Simmons got me the job he's
like hey man it pays good it was like
400 bucks all you had to do was one
Thursday but you woke up at the crack of
dawn they filled my Jetta front seat
back seat and trunk with thrifty nickels
and I had to run in Thrifty Nickel that
was like uh it was like a Savings
magazine like a savings newspaper okay
and I was and the movie singles that
just come out and so I was listening to
the soundtrack of singles movie it was
Matt Damon now no Matt Matt Matt who's
the good-looking Matt that we grew up
with that was in beautiful girls Matt I
can't I see him I see how his face Matt
Dillon it was nasty little pony boy yeah
times I said that my head in an airport
car
stay gold Ponyboy one more dude and so
it was it was a Cameron Crowe movie
jingles there it is man that whole
soundtrack your Sedgwick Eddie Vedder
Matt Dillon that was such and I listed
act that whole he's preposterous Lee
handsome he's uh he's a dude I saw him
in person he's striking we bumped into
each other and he did the Matt Dillon
hello red guy like that almost has a
curse too handsome we were trying to buy
coke at the Formosa cafe Shh it's passed
[Laughter]
he was with the little guy from from
from beautiful girls who goes she goes
hey guys sambuca and he goes what meg
too earlier too late like the little you
know the little guy from those movies he
was so good no beautiful girls one of
the greatest [ __ ] movies ever that
him with Chris Cornell who's Jenna's him
of Chris Cornell was on his right
I think that's she was famous she's
someone's daughter or something
mmm Bridget Fonda Chris Cornell was one
of the biggest bummer suicides was after
him it was from xanax right I don't know
what it was from I don't know what it
was from I mean I think there's a bunch
of different Sonny Garcia was willing to
[ __ ] me up
big big surfer from LA or from Hawaii oh
dude that bum me out so bad I'm a bit
despite not know he had a surf at all
I'm a huge surfing fan and so I was at
Sonny Garcia was like the first dude
that first you know I remember seeing
him and Kristen Fletcher had tattoos
like when you were like brother they got
tattoos what are their parents that
forever God and then but yeah he
committed suicide and like Portland or
something I seen I remember reading that
now I didn't I didn't know about him but
I think I remember reading it now um
Bourdain was the hardest one for me I
wish I'd met him I was one of the ones
where I'm like ah you know you always
think like I was so smart I wish I gotta
talk to him
was so smart you know sometimes people
think they can get in a bad way then get
in a bad way but you could pull out of
that bad way sometimes you need to know
you need to know that there's uh there's
a there's a light at the end you got an
I don't know what it was I know it was
chemical or emotional I don't know what
it was but he had so much to offer this
perspective was so unique
you're such an interesting guy like a
genuine and just you could feel the
chaos in him he was a fun guy to
discover you know like when you were
when you first found him
yeah and cuz I think a lot of people
found them on their own of their own
where they were like do this [ __ ]
show No Reservations is awesome dude I
would have loved to send you and him
it's wrong together because he made me
tap out way way camping we went pheasant
hunting in Montana and then we went
camping hard in the paint so he went
hard in the paint and I felt I couldn't
find any weed I thought I had weed but I
had a vape I had a vape pen so we busted
out the vape pen and they're passing
around the whiskey man weird
barbecued and he keeps going he just he
really he kept going he would just keep
going he wanted to go he wanted to go to
the Netherlands
he wanted to past pass into the next
dimension he wanted to escape you know
he would go hard
I would love to so interesting I just
really enjoyed his company you know he's
just I don't I didn't I never I never
knew anyone like him was a very very
different guy and I always was like
happy that he liked me because I was
always
that a guy like that could work it's
like I come off the wrong way sometimes
people you know you think you do yeah we
shirtless yeah I know
yeah I come off the wrong I come off
wholeheartedly the wrong way with
intention people go that guy is a
[ __ ] idiot I I was telling Jim Norton
this this morning when Showtime did my
special machine Helen I keep saying
Helen that's her name she works at
Showtime she made a very very wise
tactical decision she said I think you
shirtless is a bad idea I said really as
she goes I just I just think they'd be
lucky we're gonna change a channel and
man was she right I had the lowest rated
special out of all of them for the whole
year the lowest rated special and then
when I did when that story went viral it
was because my shirt was off that people
recognized it and I think I was saying
this I think it's the thing we're like
when big government puts an entity in
front of you like when when Showtime
puts out in front of you and you have
the remote you go aft that guy like
thumbs down but when you discovered on
your own online and you go shirtless guy
was that the onus is on you so you're
more forgiving you listen yeah I think
that's the cool thing about podcasts I'm
like what we do is that like I remember
I remember discovering your podcast
aiyla
you and Tommy's like must be episode
three you and Tommy were doing a podcast
I was a baby she saw Tommy buns on the
screen and clicked it it was on Twitter
good made may be my space but clicked it
and it was snowflakes and I came in and
I loved was watching you and Tom on my
laptop and I and I sat without in my lap
and I started watching it and from and I
must have been like episode three four
maybe even before he started calling the
Joe Rogan experience I was [ __ ] hooked
and I was a rider die [ __ ] like
because I found it but it's but if you
put podcast like when these guys saying
I'm gonna [ __ ] on but people sign big
deals with podcast and then podcast
company goes new podcast it's it's like
I got to find it when you find it
yourself you [ __ ] love it man and I
found I found Bourdain sitting in my bed
no reservations came on I didn't know
what it was at all didn't know anything
about Travel Channel other than man
versus food and I [ __ ] he did this
monologue that I was like - that's what
every guy hosting television wants to do
his monologues were brilliant it was a
great road he wrote yeah he was a great
writer as well as he's just just super
unique when he got into jujitsu I was so
happy yes so happy because I was [ __ ]
[ __ ] I was like yeah you're like his
knock on well yeah what's his name John
Dudley yeah John Dudley is like yeah he
gets a call from you and he's like I
Roby it's gone up I'll take it what do
you need to know about Bo's that a
brother with him it was like such an
interesting shift because when I'd known
him before he was smoking cigarettes and
then I met him act no actually I met him
after he had stopped smoking cigarettes
I knew of him when he was smoking when
he was on his television show and then
he had his daughter when he has his
daughter stopped smoking but I remember
reading that he decided to take statins
rather than clean up his diet because it
was just so important to him to eat well
and he did wasn't exercising at the time
and he was drinking a lot but it was so
important for him I mean for what he
does and what he loves to just to be
able to eat well just eat the most
delicious artistic creations master
culinary assassins and so that's what he
decided to do and then when he got to he
didn't need the high blood pressure
medication anymore or that what it was a
high cholesterol destroy he didn't need
it anymore he was his whole body like
transformed he seemed so much more when
he was on CNN he seemed so much more
grounded and and and I helped yeah but
in some ways but to me in some ways not
like in some ways I was like watching
him age very rapidly physically look how
he looked like um and I you know I love
this guy to death the towards the end I
would see images of him I was like wow
he looks he looks like he's it looks
like he's struggling like he's his body
is aging a lot and it could be just
because he's traveling so much and he's
drinking so much it could be
traveling traveling with drinking is is
very different than living at home
drinking it's rough it's all rough it's
all rough on the body you know and then
you know probably all the demons he was
battling that he succumbed to in the end
anyway
you know there's a that's there's
something about that but there was
something about that [ __ ] look that
he had when he was at that place that
was like you just wanted to talk to him
cuz he knew he had some [ __ ] to say god
man what a [ __ ] brilliant mind to my
wife was before I started watching my
wife red kitchen Confidential's is that
his was that his and my wife's like this
guy's [ __ ] amazing bird and I was and
that's I was in bed with ila and I
watched it came on TV yeah he was
awesome you've met some [ __ ]
fascinating people yeah he was one of
the first to ever do the podcast - do
you remember us like real guests famous
people who came in do you remember when
back in the this is like a throwback to
you've ever went like re was the most
fascinating person or like Brian Redman
like remember I talked about the podcast
like back in the day when you had that
landline that would ring for no reason
at all the wall who's the first guess
you got on the podcast where you're like
shut the [ __ ] up Graham Hancock oh
that's right we went and grabbed grande
king crab Hancock and I believe it was
Graham and Duncan and I and we sat down
this was way way way way way early on
and I had picked up one of Graham's
books I believe it's I always say
footprints of the gods but it's really
fingerprints of the gods I'm pretty sure
and the book was about ancient
civilizations and it was all about how
there's some there's a massive amount of
evidence that points to the possibility
that Earth experienced some sort of a
cataclysmic disaster somewhere in the
neighborhood of 12,000 years ago and
that all the stuff that we see in these
older civilizations it's really complex
and confusing the reason why it happened
and there's just like this down period
in this up period again afterwards is
because a giant percentage of the
population was wiped out by an asteroid
that they can prove hit
and he's been proven more and more and
more correct as time went on and for me
just as a fan of that subject because
like just what we're experiencing now
with this pandemic and just with life in
general we we'd love to think that
things are static and nothing static and
there's nothing sadder than someone who
doesn't recognize they're not static
anymore right there's nothing sadder
than a woman who's in her 80s she still
puts on too much makeup or you know or a
god that's that age is still doing
push-ups on the front lawn and flexing
for the neighbors good morning miss Mary
there's nothing sad about people that
don't recognize that things aren't
static and he is he's like the guy who
sounded the wake-up call in my
consciousness look at that what year was
that man September 25th 2011 Wow
suppose this podcasts been going on ten
years now yeah it started in 2010 Duncan
has nine and went to December yeah
Duncan looks exactly the same but we
have these Luther's a flashlight over my
left shoulder I was but that was listen
man you could only have done the way we
did it if you did it that way but
meaning that like no one has to be
watching no one cared
it didn't mean anything dude and we were
blasted out of our minds for the first
like 80 or 90 episodes maybe even more
I was so high during every episode Oh
remember we do the volcano shots
I remember that big [ __ ] volcano and
it would sit right next year and it we
just keep smoking the entire time so if
you had to sit next to read ban on the
right it would just burn the whole time
sometimes we'd be in the middle of
conversation I'd be like hey we started
the podcast dude I remember I remember
that time so vividly it was like it was
like a shift in the [ __ ] universe's
of like yeah I remember going to your
house I would say there's my one of my
favorite stories the way I met you is
the last way you should meet Joe I went
up to your house you were at the door
already and you were like
man I go hey man big fan I got to see
the deprivation tank your dog in a pool
table then we need to get high and then
I'm ready to do this and you were like
caught off guard you're like okay you
took me back I met John I met Johnny
Cash took me down to the deprivation
tank we played around a pool went out to
that back where the swing set and the
chickens ended up being smoked a joint
red band showed up change my [ __ ]
life you said hey man you got to tell
that machine story every time you get on
stage if you hadn't done that I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'd be doing if you
you know that well that's what happened
that first night right so I tell the
Machine story on to your podcast and you
go it's one of the best stories it's one
of the stories ever told you go ladies
and gentleman you tell on stage I go no
you know you gotta start Elemental stage
hey everybody and you talk to the you go
he is from now on known as the Machine
you yelled a machine every one of his
shows until you tell make him tell it on
stage so I go to Columbus the next week
I go do my first show Thursday man like
maybe 120 people not to not sold out and
they start chanting the Machine and I go
hey guys it's not a stage story this
dude in the front row death squad ride
or die death squad covered head-to-toe
goes hey Bert we understand it's not
gonna be funny but you got to tell it if
you're gonna want it to be good so I
told it make at the bar they're like you
know we had to fake laugh a couple times
but it's a big story cut from that
samandtom
doing our weight loss challenge right
the first time we'd enter weight loss
challenge and that machine story went
viral that week that week that machine
for a week you guys did began the
challenge or finish the challenge the
weigh-ins when he shaved my beard really
the machine story went viral that
[ __ ] week I say they go they go you
know you you I'm always saying the
luckiest dude in the world I think I
think I work hard I'm very very very
lucky I'm more lucky than anyone in the
world right just I stand by luck but man
the luckiest I've ever been is making
friends with a guy remember you telling
me I remember you coming out and saying
I was I didn't want to make friends you
came out with a [ __ ] we were at the ice
house we're doing death squad Chronicles
came out with a shot and a beer you say
hey good guy
oh yeah thanks you're like you know
we're all trying to befriend man and I
was like no I got it I get it
you're like no like like you just gotta
let us and I was like no I understand
you like no no that means like when we
call you call us back and we and you're
like no I don't think there's there you
go me Joey Ari Tommy we're all trying to
be your friend Bert well we have to tell
you I want I don't want to throw anybody
under the bus so as I explain this I'm
gonna be very careful okay
the reason why we're saying that because
we know you had been friends with a
tyrant you shellshocked like Bert you
were your real friends we like you
[ __ ] screaming little you we actually
like you we're gonna bust your balls but
we lost everyone bus everyone's balls
half the fun that is like a beatin kid
Jesus Christ we gotta lighten this
crisis yeah yeah I remember you guys
call one Saturday you go what are you
doing I go I'm on the treadmill and you
go nah come over the ice house and I
said I'm good and I hung up right and
then Tommy called me back and Tommy goes
hey man you gotta let us try to be your
friend
[ __ ] come to the ice house just come
the [ __ ] ice house and I went and then
I heard you on the get earlier and so I
[ __ ] won over the ice house I knew it
but you know that's how it is in this
[ __ ] weird business like half the fun
is finding a group of people that you
can enjoy it with it's half the fun it's
it's all the fun in my opinion you used
to tell me like about how traveling with
Joey and Tom and Ari and how much
changes the game to dye travel with a
group of guys now and it's so much fun
yeah if you get like we've been doing
push-up challenge is every night you get
wasting go [ __ ] it let's go tens of tens
Josh
Tommy's guy that he has open to powder
Josh Potter is [ __ ] hilarious huh
he's really funny man hilarious he
opened for Tommy I happened to be in
Vegas maybe like the last get out of the
year I was in Vegas for the UFC and just
coincidentally tommy was performing at
the Mirage so I came to hang out with
him we all went out we had steaks we
[ __ ] had a great time on Friday night
and then we
- to see his show and then we went to
see a show that's the first time I ever
saw Joshi murdered he's awesome he's
really funny from Buffalo we've seen ya
you'd run into him every now and then
and man Tom's Tom's with Lizzy I gotta
say Tom specials probably streaming
right now if you're watching this it's
streaming on Netflix called ball hog
he'll be on the podcast I'm sure this
Lamar oh yes tomorrow Tommy's on
tomorrow yeah but and what's good for
the goose is good for the gander we got
a podcast America cave where bears one
cave say it so people can understand the
severe wound cave you don't have to
shove it in there okay okay okay
do bears ma okay dude I get I get my
brain a wrap I'll get verbage in my head
like bats won't work I just runs I'm Mac
Lethal is yeah dude you listen to him
rap double triple yes yes his his
rapping confuses the [ __ ] out of me like
I don't even understand how someone's
lips can how about Eminem
did you hear mmm when he did that mmm
challenge you saw Jamie I'm sure cuz me
and you were both children but Mac
Lethal is probably the fastest I don't
know this Eminem challenge I wish you
could play it well I heard some mm [ __ ]
recently that was really fast too really
[ __ ] fast really fast too but I kind
of think yeah yeah if I had to put the
two of them in a fast rap off I got my
money on that lethal fellow 16 or 99
words in 16 seconds yeah 99 words in 16
seconds yeah Wow when you were younger
did you ever think like there was a
celebrity that would love your comedy
like when you were younger and you were
like nah man it's one of the weirdest
things ever was looking on the audience
and seeing famous people but took
forever to get used to that like who
whose lemons he blocked me on Twitter I
really wished I could be the consigliere
that brought you two together at this
time he was a big hockey fan though yeah
he took him to a lot of comedy shows his
son
think it's a monk and his son brought
his whole family on New Year's Eve at
the improv one one weekend yeah one one
year brother yeah it was weird
it's weird I was like Jesus Christ gene
Simmons in the [ __ ] audience when I
was a kid like I loved kiss they were
awesome when I was a kid
goddamn man it was like my favorite band
the weird Bell cuz people would mock you
if you if you loved them I was obsessed
you remember the movie they did where
they took over the park the park yes
though the power went out in the middle
of me watched and I cried weed hose it
pat Fagin's house almost been seven and
I was like I was like oh my god this is
the greatest movie ever my parents came
in they're like go home I go we're not
done we're not done I didn't really cry
but I might as well I was [ __ ] powers
off my dad my dad would wake me up and
he wait for the 7/11 commercials where
they were on Slurpees and he cranked it
up he goes shout out it shout it shout
it out loud go to school first grade
every kid that was in to kiss identified
with a particular member like my friend
Javier was really in a Peter Criss oh my
god I was hardcore into Peter Criss yeah
I met Peter Criss there were certain
dudes that thought they were Paul
Stanley certain dudes that like I I was
a gene Simmons fan I was in between
Peter Criss and Ace Frehley I bought is
really a solo album in high school
everything that I would be spiritual
enough to be tuned in the Ace Frehley
because ace field was a spaceman right
he was the dude was mellow with the
guitar with the crazy guitar he had a
really good solo album remember they did
the solo albums of the faces on it yeah
behind the New York groove yeah I love
that song dude they had some amazing
life like the branding of kiss like
meaning like you remember them in the
suits yeah picture them in the suits
yeah dressed to kill yeah that was a
[ __ ] dude hate that I hate gene
Simmons like I wanna love him so bad
it's so hard to remember the story but I
saw it one day someone sent it to me one
of my friend said to me us talking about
you hating gene Simmons oh my god I kind
of forgot about that a bad interaction
with them there it is
bad ass in clogs he's wearing clogs
there there were different kinds of
people back then god I feel like there's
no way we would ever be able to
understand what life was like being a
bunch of dudes who were world famous
wearing makeup mocked openly mocked by
so many members of the music community
whether it's radio stations they
wouldn't play they thought they were a
joke and you were a fool if you liked
their music and then they take their
makeup off for a little bit remember
that kiss unmasked
I remember that it wasn't nobody was
into it he's like you want to see what
gene Simmons looks like I was like hard
pass but they wore everybody out
they wore everybody out they stayed in
the game I mean they replaced two
members Ace Frehley and Peter Criss that
kind of rotated in now and eventually
they replaced him with new people that
played the same characters this is a new
dude is the cat dude and a new dude
who's a space dude and for a while they
tried to do it different like they added
a fox one guy was Fox
[Music]
yeah when Peter Criss was gone they put
in some new dude instead of a cat he was
like a fox it was a real problem and the
the hardcore kiss fans like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know as a hardcore
kiss fan who Kevin James no Kevin James
two nights in a row went to see kiss in
LA I think I think it was at the forum
during their comeback tour cuz we
thought they were never gonna come back
again so this is me and Kevin James and
man I don't know what year that was but
it was in the 90s who's that guy that's
the Fox Eric Carr
yeah he's a flatcar yeah yeah get the
[ __ ] out of here bro nice guy great
musician don't get me wrong
Kevin James and I could not be more
different
yeah he's it he's a great guy he's a
great guy music Gary you would love I
know I know Kevin but I mean if you
really knew him like I knew him oh yeah
I'm tight with them you know I hooked
him up with my manager we we have the
same manager we have from the very
beginning I'm
Kevin for [ __ ] 29 years Gary and I were
tight
Gary Valentin I was tight with Gary - I
love a great guy Gary Valentine one of
my favorite stories ever one time we're
at the improv and he goes brettski
shot I go yeah Gary any crabs he grabs
two shots and he hands me one and then
he grabs his and he takes this back when
the improv had candles and he does a
shot of a candle wax Oliver zips goes I
took the wrong one okay Gary Valentine
is the [ __ ] funniest human being man
thank you shot a candle just splashed on
his line I can't be good yeah the is
interesting what are they what are their
pit their real name is not there don't
be giving up the real name you [ __ ] [ __ ]
I choose Christ Bert Kreischer causing
trouble yeah they both got different
names but they're brothers and sisters
yeah Kevin's a he's an interesting cat
he really is yeah very interesting guy
very quiet we sat one time in this house
when me and Gary and a couple other guys
you know I was getting wasted and he was
just sitting there looking at me and he
was like hey what are you partying for
just enjoying it and he goes what I go
all your success and he's like huh I
said Kevin I would be doing it so
different about you he was he was so you
I remember he drove like a I want to say
a Jeep Cherokee on his third season the
king of queens yeah he had like he was
very conservative
never yeah well he's he's a guy who
plays the cards close to his chest you
know such a sweet dude he introduced me
to guacamole he's not the only reason
why I've ever been in any movies well I
did some terrible movies that nobody saw
before but like the movies that I did
once I didn't need to do anything
anything anymore anymore in terms of
acting was his movies I did two of his
music I did a new keeper and I did here
comes the boom and the only reason why I
did it was cuz I love Kevin he's such a
great zoo keeper was fun - it was so
ridiculous I had to learn how to dance
it's like it took months and months of
my time it was really interesting I saw
that dance
Sebastian milk out
some in all fairness some of what you
see is not actually me some of it is me
but there was this dude who was a
professional dancer who was like a
stand-in yeah who was amazing he was
amazing so the the stuff where it's
clearly me I definitely did a lot of the
stuff all the stuff with me and leslie
bibb we're at a holder and all that
stuff that was me a hundred percent but
this is so much better than me where you
couldn't tell they stuck him in you know
and he was like built like me and he
would it was perfect it was like nobody
could tell because because he was really
good like when you see how hard it is to
actually dance you go my god like when
you see a real professional it's one of
the most dismissed things with people
oh we dismiss it like oh what a
frivolous pursuit and I knew how to
dance but if you can really dance it's
so impressive when someone has like full
control of their body that's what Tom
said to me because I'm a better dancer
than him dude I did [ __ ] Tom let me tell
you something that [ __ ] my
daughter's my daughter's my daughter's
saw Tom's video and they looked at in
there like wait Tom can dance I go you
didn't say that when you saw my video
and they go you paid someone to teach
you how to dance I go so too [ __ ] he
you think he did that on his own they go
it looks like it I tried to do that
Irish dance for the release of the
special but you got appreciate the fact
that Tom did it in a Steven Seagal out
but little carrot don't ever like if you
I swear to god if you watch the video of
me watching that for the first time it's
a love letter it's a man reading a love
letter from his boyfriend when Tom's I
said I he goes how do you feel I said
like privately I go made me feel very
honored that you did that he goes
because I love you like so like when he
put that out I meant so much because I
go because I thought I put out my dance
video and everyone made fun of it and we
watched it we giggled but the fact that
it inspired Tom to drop eighty thousand
whatever he spent eighty five hundred
thousand ten thousand it the fact that
he made a reply video made me so [ __ ]
excited when I went so deep
so Joe was your nice do you realize what
he did he made me he told us he goes i
sat and did facial recognition for him
yeah we talked about it oh he [ __ ] you
hard bro bro you have no idea the times
I stay up I'm bad going this home
getting Tommy I swear to God when the
guy had the machine shirt on we sell
those it you sell those now and they're
[ __ ] going crazy they're all at my
show is just muck Sheen it's fun to
watch our fans
like our fans go back like go back and
forth with us and like bust balls with
us because that's all all we do yeah but
I know it is it's it is fun it's cool
that our specials are airing
back-to-back cuz I think was look I I
want his special I want his special be
number one running on Netflix without a
doubt but don't worry about it no no no
mine will be number two it looks like
you ate Joey Diaz poor guy that's a real
person
Wow gentlemen should take this time to
better himself we can all do better I
can sometimes people just go off the
rails that guy uh it's diet man diet
diets everything it's a but I'm not on
the carnivore diet during all this
craziness because I'm just eating yeah
I'm just eating calories because I like
the supply chain and the way things are
there's no way I can justify only eating
meat unless I'm only eating my meat like
the elk meat that I eat and how much I
got a lot for you done freezer bags for
you [ __ ] yes um I like to I love giving
it away to man I love when people cook
it but other than that it's like I need
to eat food like I'm not concentrating
on weird diets or it makes sure I I mean
I could eat only meat but I'm not even
thinking about that right now what I'm
thinking about right now is like making
sure that I make the right decisions
with
everything that I do from here out
because I think we're in unsung
territory or in Neverland
how long do you think you can go I don't
know I don't know but here's the thing
we will this is what I really feel like
we all got to do this together like it's
not the the problem is even thinking how
long can you last as part of the problem
is even thinking that well how long can
we last how long can all all of us last
and I think this is if the power goes
out that's when we're really forced to
cooperate and I don't want the power to
go out I want us to figure it out before
that happened I want us to take this
plunge into the apocalypse and baby
steps here's my question would you host
a shitty gameshow know if it may hold on
if it meant giving money to people and
need a money in this time they go hey
Joe we want you to host who wants to be
a millionaire but why would I do that
that way when I could do it right here
I'm just saying I'm just never doing
anywhere else no yeah no I don't want a
boss you can't do it I can't well
nothing you do you could do if someone
was looking over your shoulder telling
you what to do some corporate guy who
just wants to make sure that he can keep
paying his mortgage and funding his
lifestyle and you know he's got a lot of
experience producing television shows
just let me handle this stuff and you do
your job and I'll do my job
Burt we gotta have a talk you drink too
much you're getting too fat your belly's
out all the time and networks don't like
it the next thing you know you're some
[ __ ] different day it's well but and
and I'm sure you appreciate the gig he
got a Travel Channel just like I
appreciate the gig I got a fear factor
but it's not that it's not a great job
it is a great job it's just like
everything in life if you have higher
expectations of yourself if you want to
express yourself in the most accurate
way the best at being comfortable in
your own skin the only way you can do
that is by yourself yeah you can't have
some [ __ ] giant bankrolled machine
with hundreds of employees all with
their job riding on whether or not you
say the N word Jesus part hundreds of
people in the corporation
[ __ ] he's drunk can't rap lyrics you
can't you can't say those words do you
realize how many times if there was a
corporate raising behind bird
entertainment they were like [ __ ] are
you doing well that's what the irony
isn't it
the irony is look how successful it is
without any of that intervention if you
just are yourself if you just are
authentic and that's what you are and
that's why it works that's why all
podcasts work they work precisely
because there's not a machine behind
them
yeah there's not a giant corporation
behind them that counts on them then
work because they're they're independent
that's the only way you get real people
that for the [ __ ] thing that you get
when you make people behave in this
weird way it's not a good thing it's
like you're not getting an accurate
representation of what it is to be a
person you can't count in there they're
just lying to you I mean that's why
politicians and political speeches are
so strange
they almost universally act like no one
you've ever met yeah when they do in
those speeches when they're stand in
front of a podium doing that thing with
their thumb and and doing their best
Barack Obama impression you're literally
putting on an act yeah putting on I have
no idea who you are you might be a
morning DJ from [ __ ] Cincinnati hey
here we come coming at you with the hits
it's not 13 to 6 here you're up too
early people you're the people getting
it done all right I mean how many of
those guys were interchangeable how many
of those guys were interchangeable and
they would you could put them in a strip
club they could be a strip club DJ they
could be a regular DJ top 40 there was a
voice now when someone's talking in that
voice you have no idea what their real
thoughts are you have no idea if you
didn't got a clue and that's most of
what we got with like the Today Show
like if Matt Lauer had a podcast and it
turned out that he was a pig
I'm great with people people would be
like I knew that guy was a pig
Billy would be so [ __ ] awesome is
helium into it well if he was just who
he actually was right like when you're
doing a show like that like something
like Today Show one of the reasons why
people are so angry is because you've
been pretending you're this like
wholesome character all this time yeah
you've been pretending how great would
it be if Matt Lauer did his Matt Lauer
voice but he was talking about porn he
jacked off to his legs anyone seen
tentacle porn and back right now from
eight o'clock hour it's Matt Lauer going
up again wouldn't it be better if you
figured out how to not be that guy that
you are on TV and just be who you are
when the TV's off I don't think he knew
who he was ever I think he was the I
think what define Matt Lauer was being
famous it defined a lot of us getting
into this business and then I think a
lot of it shifted
I think the good ones stuck to what they
wanted to go what they wanted to be and
I think a lot of people still just want
to be famous I think it just it well you
know why one of the reasons why is
because it's hard to be but it's hard to
be famous yeah
so when there's a thing that out there
that's hard to get like mmm how [ __ ]
do I get that you ever seen like some
some people their intelect exclusive
things yeah you know you know I mean
like you only want one like if there's
only four these bags in North America
I've got to get it ya know girls would
get like certain bag shoes guys get
shoes yeah yeah yeah Travis Scott oh
yeah there's a lot of dudes are into
Jordans
like specific old school Jordans I'm
looking at you well you're in a sneakers
your sneaker head right yeah any speaker
spins a pandemic I about one pair lasts
oh you are a horribly on sale for Conor
bucks I get it man I get it I get it I
get it in some ways but you were saying
people that are into elite things
correlating it's at the famous people
yeah it's hard to get that bag and it's
hard to get famous so when you're not
famous it looks like a thing that would
be cool to have like oh look look at
this [ __ ] walk on that red carpet damn
look at those shoes that [ __ ] she paid
three hundred thousand dollars for that
outfit
yeah look at this so that cars got out
of that's a million-dollar Bugatti get
man if you're driving around town and
the [ __ ] 2001 Honda Accord and you
see someone step out about bugatti
veyron that you know cost a million
dollars of holy [ __ ]
you know there's certain there's certain
things you see that you just get like
really jealous of not because you would
actually want them but because they're
so unattainable yeah and people [ __ ] up
with that that's why girl get asses that
are too big
all right get crazy and they get this
bizarre diaper ass with these little
skinny legs and the two things don't
work together why it's because they they
overshot the mark right you painted your
house pink slow down okay you had a bad
idea and you ran with it I saw some guy
who built something on his house that
was basically a [ __ ] you to his neighbor
he built like a middle finger somehow I
was three chimneys he had three trees
like this to build like a [ __ ] you to
his neighbor that is literally [ __ ] you
money I think he got in trouble for it I
think the I think maybe he like said
something about or something that's you
that's to you I wrote that cuz I [ __ ]
hate you Johnny Depp has a big gorilla
flipping off his neighbor I think a girl
like a huge [ __ ] Jew that's like 18
houses but he wives he wanted the last
one on the block oh there's someone to
buy and the guy wouldn't sell that's
right he owns like a whole block here's
a whole block spent the night at his
house one time okay let's slow down oh
dude I have a voicemail from Johnny Depp
I haven't deleted
I enjoy talking to him man he was [ __ ]
[ __ ] awesome I was drunk on margaritas
in Hawaii and Stanhope put me on the
phone with Johnny Depp and I was like
man how weird is my life
dude I'm sitting there talking to Johnny
Depp while I'm hammered in a lawn chair
in Hawaii dude haven't Stanhope called
me one night and I let it go to
voicemail I regret it so much but I got
it on voicemail but Johnny I'm a dog you
know me and Tom are working on the
script with Johnny are you really good
we pitched it on the podcast and I was
like and then all the sudden everyone
got interested and I was like [ __ ]
I'll write it I tell you what I enjoyed
talking to him he's a very wise guy he's
he's a very when you talk to him he's
there you know he's a dude experiencing
something that a small fraction of all
the humans who have ever lived have been
able to experience he's experienced Fame
I'm the most preposterous and staggering
level imaginable and then he's
experienced that it's almost like he
owes people something so he's being held
to these standards that that none of us
would ever want our own lives to be held
to and some weird [ __ ] legal battle
between who who did who - what - what
happened and his recordings and all this
chaos like god damn like living this out
in the open like this it's all like just
it's sad because you look at him in a
different way because of that not when
you watching the Pirates movies
he's brilliant he is something so good
in those movies like so good on so many
levels that I've seen them all and we
just the first week of pandemic we just
watched all of them all over yeah Donnie
Brasco Donnie Brasco is [ __ ] amazing
he's so gloat and blow he's [ __ ] out
of this world he's he's one of the best
actors we've ever had one of the best
American actors that have ever existed
for sure Liddell and you and Keith I'm
telling you as someone who talks to
crazy people all the time and talking to
him he's is remarkably put together as
you could ever expect a person to be
that's as famous as he is he's a really
good guy like you talked to me is there
he's talking he's just talking to you
there's no he's there for you he's
talking
yes a good guy he's just experiencing
something no one is prepared for he's
Johnny Depp Johnny Depp he's Johnny Depp
Johnny Depp's are there this one [ __ ]
is one [ __ ] 1 billion people on this
planet he's experiencing some weird [ __ ]
you know he's not a bad guy dude Edward
Scissorhands she just tell me everything
I mean that guy is movies is he done how
many movies out let's ballpark it I'm
gonna say 50 yeah I think you're right i
T liked was that 21 Jumpstreet
[Music]
pretty cougar he got killed in Freddy
Krueger he comes back it's like let's
find a way to have a guy with claws four
fingers killed by the worst guy with
claws four fingers there's three guys
historically in film with claws four
fingers Wolverine but he's was different
cuz they came out of his knuckles right
they always confused because they get
broken off but still came back for
Freddy had him on his feet oh my God
look at that belly to belly he was
beautiful there's a beautiful man like
that's not a normal development
congratulations to him from making it to
be as normal as he is but he was always
with this guy who is one of the worst
with the claws or fingers and then he
becomes Edward Scissorhands who's just
kind of confused what a stretch is a
character to to play that as this I
confused my name in colleges has Edward
penis lips you know another weird things
he did you know what I really enjoyed
what the Lone Ranger the more recent
never saw it he played a Comanche and
there was a this is like I've kind of
got into this when I was reading empire
of the summer moon is a book about
Comanches I bought it on audiobook it's
amazing yeah I say reading I'm lying I
listen to an audiobook too but then I
started reading things about it online
and one things I started reading about
it is that Johnny Depp played a command
in this movie and actually like did some
weird [ __ ] like a tie like a stuffed
bird on his head which apparently some
of the Comanches and some different
Indian tribes would actually do like
Crazy Horse even do the NES tough talk
yeah on his head but uh like he played
this like really weird character man
like yeah he played but it was a really
weird time it was outside so wasn't uh
it was like super [ __ ] natural
spiritual Tonka Tonto who brings the
Lone Ranger back from the dead yeah he
brings it back from the dead of that
movie but it's a dope movie but you're
interested in it because of Johnny Depp
it's part of me think the characters so
ridiculous this Native American guy that
brings someone back to dead but Johnny
Depp plays it so hardcore he plays it so
to the bone that it's like you really
pull this this guy brought him back from
the dead that Tonto the the right the
original Tonto his [ __ ] gotten a lot
of [ __ ] trouble towards the end of
his life for playing red face how did he
yeah they called it his red face is like
not really Native American I thank you
is that what you're saying or is it that
he was Native American but that he
played Native American in movies I'm a
little high think he's Mexican oh no how
did well well maybe he's maybe he's like
poor part more Mexican part Native
American
well the fact is that he talked like me
so horny that's it it's his chimney oh
yeah outside of it is cactus that's a
cactus it was like paid to do oh oh you
said it wasn't a chimney yeah
oh so it's just cactus I found to be
true that like you do this to piss off
the councilman neighbors
mm-hmm yeah he didn't like them but I
would I'd be like oh my god this guy's
hilarious imagine the amount of effort
he put in to look at that right in his
backyard so ridiculous and that's a
councilman that's why yeah and so that's
why you brought it up that's this
transient effect Utah yeah people more
people gonna pay attention that guy
hates you see if you can find Johnny
Depp's gorilla
a gorilla a gorilla I think I saw it he
owns a gorilla no no like a big gorilla
inflatable gorilla [ __ ] flip flipping
off his neighbor I think I touched it
what damn how much do you drink there is
yeah yeah yeah what does it say giant
deaf I was pretty wasted when I was
there
gorilla in congratulatory for so he has
this sculpture right into his neighbor's
backyards he wanted to buy the house and
they wouldn't sell it
well he's let that go I love his hats be
a good neighbor
I love his hats he's a guy who could
pull off hats great jaw line it's almost
like he's apologizing for being so
good-looking so he dresses goofy I would
love to get to that place where I
started wearing [ __ ] outrageous
outfits do you do that just lose a lot
of weight like from here on out yeah if
you come out of this better than anybody
like let's maybe maybe that's one thing
we should do what's that
maybe all of us should get together and
have a quarantine challenge maybe we
should get together come on man what'd
you say open-ended he's scared of an end
no I'm just kidding a finish line I'm so
into this no this is all my brain
working like for all of us like what
better way to turn this into a positive
then until I just make some sort of
healthy competition out of it I'll a
sober October yeah yeah I'm I love it
yeah yeah I gave myself a break tonight
to boot today with booze I brought weed
just in case no podcast
yeah sure you got a big comedy special
on Netflix we got to have fun it was a
success this is perfect perfect
everything everything if you had told me
in college
Amen you know that guy news radio you're
gonna party without you I'd be like
[ __ ] drive to [ __ ] him he's like
naughty dick it's juggen i mean this is
like my life's worked out pretty good
all of our lives have men you know for
me to be me he's one of the weirdest
things to you know that I could wrap my
head around I'm have a hard time
wrapping my head around it all the time
and do you like and I not too
back to this but like it brings back
perspective of like like honestly just
like how [ __ ] lucky we are and like
when I think immediately I go wait staff
at the [ __ ] store you gotta you gotta
help man like I'm like overwhelmed by
that we need to do like a comic relief
or something big on our platforms that
we can do where we can raise money we
could definitely do that we should
definitely donate as well you know I'm
donating I'm waiting for them to set
something up but I think we should
continue to donate and I think that
particularly with the people that we you
know we have a system of all of us
there's the waitstaff
there's the management staff as the
kitchen staff and all these places and
they've all taken a big hit and and it's
far worse for them that it would be for
the same amount of money for us so I
think we could pick up some slack yeah I
think we all do that together and we'll
figure it out like a good system within
all the clubs we can keep everybody ok I
think that's that's doable I don't think
that's bad I think that would be great
for all of us a thing that'd be great
for all of us as a community you know
we'll realize ok we can all chip in we
could help each other
you know I have a lot of meat that I've
been giving out a lot of my comedian
friends you know I'll be taking some of
that yeah man that makes me real happy
cause when I got into bow and arrows
good we're not gonna be able to rebuild
the new house anymore but you know it's
not gonna last forever and this is gonna
be a I hope not at least this is gonna
be a opportunity it's gonna be this is
the best thing you could say it's an
opportunity for us like you know one can
say it's going to be this or it's going
to be that I mean I've heard a lot of
people to try to either comfort people
or they try to push their point across
almost if they can win this argument
then they're it's more likely to be true
and it's comforting and some sort of a
weird way but no one knows no one know
no one knew that it would go - no one
knew four months ago no one knew four
months ago but four months later would
be here no.10 people knew that so if we
didn't know that like what we don't know
what's coming in four months from now it
can compound this is still right now
even in quarantine the best time that
humans have ever had ever
earth you know obviously not for the
people that are the victims of the
disease but we can be okay coming out of
this and it could be a wake-up call for
people to stop living these lives that
are unsatisfying and and and you know
and figure out a way where we stopped
chasing [ __ ] it's my whole [ __ ]
life stop chasin [ __ ] it's amazing
man it just perspective it and I think I
don't know if I walk away with any
[ __ ] perspective than a better man
I think cuz I'm now I was in the on the
tour every week every week [ __ ] burn
it I remember like I could I keep going
back to this conversation with Ali Wong
she's like you're touring like it's
going away and I was like I was like
yeah right
she pulled me aside in the hallway
tomorrow are and goes hey Tornillo huh
yeah yeah he's good yeah you're torn
like it's going away I go ultimately you
were right see this is what I was
talking about lady it might be gone for
six goddamn months we have no idea I
mean I don't know I mean they might have
I mean I literally know nothing about
when the window of vaccine is I've heard
elaborate numbers from 12 months to 18
months I do not know I've heard all
sorts of different stuff about promising
medications and this is within the first
couple of months do not know there might
be something they come off within a
month or two who knows
do you not know the cool thing about the
news cycle is waiting for hope like
waiting for like to get online and get
excited and go oh breakthrough today or
that's why I like you god damn man once
the [ __ ] goes sideways that's when you
need a really good leader you really do
yeah you need someone who is honest when
all the [ __ ] goes away when
everyone's worried about and
invisible monster that wants to kill
your grandma what's a sneak into her
lungs and shut them down
when people are worried about that kind
of [ __ ] you really want someone who has
their character and order you know and
this is this is one of the things that
we should really take deeply into
consideration when we talk about someone
being a president or any any politician
anyone who's a leader how are they how
do they gonna react when [ __ ] goes
sideways how are they gonna keep it
together are they gonna make you feel
good about this the reality of this
world are they gonna just freak you out
with [ __ ] are they're gonna make you
feel less connected to it because you
know that their words are not honest and
that they're not accurate they're not
they're not heartfelt it's just spitting
out [ __ ] and you're like [ __ ] this
goddamn cars going sideways down the
highway and no one knows what to do
that's why we need to vote for the rock
no I'd vote for him Senate Rae Hynie in
100% I would I'm all in for the rock as
good as he is about everything else in
life he'd be great a president but no
one should be President yeah but the
rock could like what you need is a
figurehead to let you know how today is
gonna work out yeah as like you said
those inspirational speeches mean a lot
yeah and and the rock could give us
every morning from the iron jungle just
like guys big day legs hey listen the
economy's doing yeah but right now
everyone loves the rock if he became
president 40% of the people would
immediately start hating him no yes
unify the country impossible can't be
done we love it just be mean he's got
biceps say bunch of mean [ __ ] to him and
then a tribute to his decisions what the
economy is doing and what this is doing
in that I like that why would he do that
I just keep doing Jumanji movies and
everybody loves him Jumanji movies are
so [ __ ] good this one
aquafina was the [ __ ] home run yeah
which she came up Soleri dude I texted
her like oh no her that well and
kind of named Robin no no I I called her
out on like Instagram going hey this is
[ __ ] amazing awkwafina's amazing my
daughter's love Aquafina lover she
replies he was like hey thank you
she played Danny DeVito look I'm sitting
here watching Kevin are doing the Jewish
accent going the [ __ ] going on
when Aquafina came in I went chill bumps
she was walking around with she was she
stole the movie at that point but the
rock when the rock goes off brand and he
goes listen yeah we got [ __ ]
this is mother [ __ ] I get my heart
skips of beatings when He pours it to
Kela and you're like wait is the middle
you afternoon I love the rock yeah no
he's when he was playing Danny DeVito
was hilarious dude they were oh that's
right Kevin Hart was playing a
twenty-one lethal weapon
Danny Glover Danny Glover yeah yeah yeah
yeah hard funniest yeah and in the rock
was playing Danny DeVito those two mangy
movies do not let down just as good if
not better than the first one the first
one ice came out her and I said girls is
the best movie you'll ever seen in your
entire life I'm 47 years old you'll
never feel better one Billy it was a
perfect movie that you could take your
family to and the second one was the
same way it's a great movie if you're
looking for a family movie to watch on
lockdown right now and you haven't seen
Jumanji - it's excellent it's really
good it's fun man Kevin Hart is a talent
he's a special talent so and that
redheaded throws kicks that chick is
badass gorgeous back like a [ __ ] it's
fun to watch him be not something other
than Jack like what he's good at they do
two plays a football player fridge he's
always yeah yeah the the Instagram
influence or she uh it's a great cast
man it's amazing [ __ ] movie yeah it's
funny to know Kevin Hart like my
daughter the other day so it's not about
Kevin Hart and I said something she goes
well you act like you know him I go yeah
yeah I know Kevin she goes you don't
know Kevin Hart maybe the [ __ ] I don't
know Kevin Hart I know I'm like what are
you talking about no Kevin Hart's
brother is like a legit professional
pool player Kevin Hart's brother is in
the front row at the DC Improv one night
and I'm making jokes I'm [ __ ] some
[ __ ]
horrible joke and he's laughing hard and
I say you look like [ __ ] you look
like a dirty ass Kevin Hart or something
and he goes I'm his brother and I went
sure yard he goes no I'm his [ __ ]
brother I go no you're not and he goes
I'm his [ __ ] brother he pulls out his
idea go oh [ __ ] he's his brother I told
her yeah I told him all the Kevin Hart
stories I had he's a legit professional
pool player for real yeah like really
good yeah I watched videos of him play
and I was like oh this guy plays like a
pro like he's he plays like if you're
watching like any like real professional
play if you ever catch ESPN nine ball
events like Johnny Archer playing Earl
Strickland or Shane van boning he plays
like those guys like legitimate really
plays like a pro yeah I watched him play
I was like oh he's like a real pro Wow
did you watch that documentary and
documentaries don't [ __ ] this up with
Kevin Hart no I did pretty like legit
back surgery yeah like cut down a spine
what did they have to do I don't know
what drove by the [ __ ] accident
driving to work one guy
yeah that's his brother yeah his brother
plays really good like really good like
it's a person who's been playing pool
I've been playing pool for almost 30
years
when I watch the play I was like I'm
like oh okay he's like watch this he's
doing this drill watch he's going across
and he's making room for his brothers
legit good oh yeah no like like a real
professional pool player and he give he
has his like videos that he'll put out
of instructional drills like he's doing
right here this is a positional drill
that he's doing to try to get in line
for each each ball Iseman well I [ __ ]
up here he's got a yes oh oh he goes the
other way once you pass the side pocket
then you go the other way oh that's
interesting so the whole idea is just
just drilling cutting balls in off the
rail is very difficult to do and he's
doing it like it got like mica imminent
or someone like that like a like a real
professional he's really good like I
watched him play and I said I said Kevin
in text message I wrote dude your
brother is [ __ ] legit like he's a
real pool player his brother mmm holy
[ __ ]
yeah dude he's really good like he's a
guy that like looks like he could win
like he's playing Darren Appleton
Darrin Appleton is like he was a top
snooker player in England and then came
allure played America he actually I
think he played English 8-ball too but
then he came over to America and started
dominating in pool and so that guy's
playing guys like that
so Kevin Hart's brothers playing like
top-notch world beaters in pool
tournaments whatever that is is good
created two [ __ ] monsters their mom
like how sexist piece of [ __ ] it's just
the dads come that did everything no
none of us the dad is the dad ignoring
them through their child funny that men
always think that whatever his dad it's
all daddy issues good genes
his dad must have been a [ __ ] Savage
hey I'll do that though it's all dad
issues that's why you succeed it's cuz
you want to please your dad I think I
don't know that's uh that kid it could
be that could it be it's not see that
whenever we try to make your motivation
for anything or your reason for success
a binary thing a one or a zero it's like
there's a lot of factors a lot of
factors heartbreak could lead people to
success whoo some guys get their heart
broken
let's mean they just go oh okay I'm
gonna show you
time to teach everyone who didn't want
to [ __ ] me that they wanted to [ __ ] me
and they no time to teach someone who
says that you're a loser someone who
used to love and they chastise you and
say you're a loser and you're like oh
you think so okay well I'll check in you
with you I'll check in with you in about
six years I don't see how this works out
there's girls I want to give trophies to
God like hey man you did it you told me
I was gonna make it and I want to thank
you so much you can do that to people
you know in those emotional moments I
could say the most mean [ __ ] because
they know that it's gonna hurt but
sometimes it works sometimes it works I
didn't even know I was fat until Tom
told me I was fat I thought it was
good-looking look at those videos I go
that's hilarious
Oh like I'm fine
I thought I was opaque perfect I was
like oh you're talking about I grew a
beard I can't see it anymore yeah it's
funny like fat shaming feels bad but
sometimes you have to feel bad to make
changes yeah but so sometimes fat
shaming could be like the most valuable
thing anybody could ever do to you but
you don't want anybody to do it to
anybody I don't want anybody to do it to
me I don't want to do it to anybody
however it's very valuable if it happens
it's like a gold that can make you rich
but it could also burn your hand should
you pick it up as I said I think you
probably should you'll heal from the
burn I listen to this app when I run is
called active and there's this guy
Hakeem and who sometimes the is coaching
we were talking about coaching my wife
losing weeks you got a trainer
sometimes coaching can get to the heart
of what you need and there's a part of
this [ __ ] run I do with a team where
he goes you know all those people that
talk [ __ ] about you and I go Tommy
tell them they're wrong ago Tommy pushes
this next on I always crank it up a
little higher I go do you have any
regret for underperforming and the so
October why didn't you get after I
couldn't I never could I never could it
got it
[ __ ] in my head my OCD [ __ ] up Oh
every time every time it [ __ ] my head
up there was so much trash talking
everybody wanted to beat you yeah
everybody just wanted to get ahead of
you I got so overwhelmed by those by are
sober October's like so overwhelmed at
one point Tom talked me off a ledge and
he goes hey remember you're just a
comedian you are not an athlete you're
just Bert and you're a comedian don't
lose sight of that because I would get
like I would get over [ __ ] whelmed
every 1st of October easy-peasy we all
did 15 so sober what's more god it's hot
yoga's yeah easy easy what happened was
the next one I rolled into like no big
thing and you did a hike with Marshall
and I did a hike without a dog and I
pretended I lost my dog but the whole
joke said I lost my dog but I was like
Joe you do one mile I do - you do two
miles I before and then I was like I'm
here with my dog Priscilla Priscilla
so and then I pretend to lose Priscilla
right it was a joke yeah and that's when
I flushed a fire igniting you that I had
none beans of high school and I was like
oh [ __ ] and then I started getting like
overwhelmed and I wasn't sleeping I was
like getting up to run and my sciatica
was hurting it was like it was so
[ __ ] aggressive that like all the fun
that I rolled into when when Tom and I
did the weight loss challenge and I just
drank the whole time and lost like 40
pounds all that fun cuz so lost in the
silver October I was like I gotta
[ __ ] win man
I gotta [ __ ] win yeah I haven't
experienced anything like that since I
was about 20 to 21 years old those the
last time I experienced that kind of
obsession something physical it leaked
into the marathon we were in here
talking about the marathon and then all
of a sudden me and Tommen already were
at the wrote the an NCAA championship
game for the you know payoff I was like
I entered the LA Marathon and Tom goes
why I said I'm gonna run a marathon and
he goes you don't have to I don't know
why you're doing it and I said cuz you
guys said I couldn't and he goes no no
we don't care and I was like I'm gonna
do it like I was lost
yeah I ran the LA Marathon I remembered
but there's an attachment I have to
whatever that focus is where I go I do
it for specials where I get so dialed in
it's an is really unhealthy but it's not
because that's how you create something
great like when you do a special I know
how much energy you put into it you
think about I I was obsessed obsessed
because I go I with this special I was
like I don't want to be the guy that
does the same special three times in a
row I want to grow I want to want to
create I want to show like my big
[ __ ] white whale was like that
Starbucks bid I do where I go do you see
that one mention your name yeah and I go
that's for me and this is like way over
thinking it's guy walks into a bar right
it was like there's a No Mas to an
old-school joke
in mind the way I tell stories yeah and
it defines me laughing at jokes but and
it and it calls my friends it was like
my favorite joke ever written I love
without obsessions not healthy man it's
not healthy to be a regular dude it's
not that it's not healthy I don't agree
with that I just think it has to be
balanced out I think it is healthy
because you know that like that bit when
it came out it was [ __ ] killer and it
needed that you know and even all that
obsession for it to grow that's how a
bit that's a great bit we have a bit you
really enjoy I really cracks when you
get up there and people really laugh
hard it's hard to make one of those and
I think there's the the it's it's worth
it for you giving into that obsession so
that the audience could experience like
a really well-crafted really rockin joke
it's fun there's no other way to make
them man I can't I don't know another
way dude I don't think there is another
way the every special that I've ever put
out
I've always [ __ ] hated immediately
afterwards I can't believe people like
this crap you [ __ ] hate I'm it's over
Josh Potter said to burn and of our
forebears one gave our guy goes Haman I
loved you special and I went really
[Music]
he was bring me a gun that's awesome and
Josh Potter's it means he's like you
gonna bits awesome and I'm looking at
time I go Tom did you think it was
awesome because we all thought I was
awesome and I was like for reals
like I dude I know you hate it because
you see it too much god there's you
gotta realize if you're seeing a special
over and over and over and over and over
again all the surprise is gone right
so you're just analyzing the like the
mechanics of the the bits and maybe I
did this one's better in the first show
but that one's better in the second hmm
but you're not experiencing what it's
like to not know where you're going the
audience is the only one that gets
experienced that so it's so hard for you
to get it and then the one thing I
always say and I'm gonna say it again
because it's just true I don't you gonna
say you're in the audience watching a
special you're getting a hundred percent
if you're at home watching on Netflix
you might get seventy I don't think you
really get seventy you probably at sixty
probably it's 60 percent of what
it's like to be in the room because as a
human there's something about laughing
in a room full of 2,000 other people
that are laughing and you're all your
little buzz you like get on stage you
take your shirt off and they go yeah and
everybody's into it it's like this it's
a big part of what stand-up comedy is is
like doing it
Lotso you're almost just getting a
reference point it's like Google Maps
when you're watching it in real life
watching on YouTube or something like
that or watching on Netflix it's like
Google Maps because it's not like being
there like if you if you stood there on
the ground you're like oh this looks
different on the ground like you liked
in you're like okay the mountains this
way and I was looking at Google Maps I
couldn't text I'm looking down on this
thing that's what it's like when you're
in the audience of a comedy club is like
being there versus watching on Netflix
which is like Google Maps it's way
better than not being there Maps is dope
you can go visit the [ __ ] rain forest
you just go look in there spread it out
pictures the [ __ ] ground looks like
from the sky but it's not gonna be like
going to the Amazon I that's what it one
of the obsessions I have with my last
not this one the last one was know what
I had one experience with TIG Notaro
take Notaro man taught me the big one of
the biggest lessons I ever learned and
stand-up we did premium blend together
and she went first and she for the first
time in life probably sucked a dick like
literally sucked a dick was so bad on
stage and and she'll admit it she'll
admit it and I went up after and I
murdered I 1,300 people I murdered I
watched the taping take destroyed
because her jokes were amazing
she and play for the room she played for
the people in the audience good people
in television and I went that's so
interesting Here I am like raising my
voice like going like what's up
UCLA like everyone homes like dude dial
your [ __ ] down I learned so much after
watching TIG that I went don't play for
the people in the room play for play for
them in the room but but make sure be
cognizant that you're making this for a
television show I don't know whether she
meant to do that on purpose or not but
man I watched her set on that premium
blend she murdered and I bombed
on TV and I was like you do yeah don't
go in and go what's up Jacksonville I
wouldn't see you murdered in person but
bombed on TV on TV because I possible my
energy was so hard in person because it
was 13 other people convinced you the
bombing on TV you can pull up that
premium blend set but you did well in
front of the crowd in front of the crowd
but I was playing louder on the mic too
much we might have I just had a good TIG
Notaro sucking dick joke I was trying to
slide it just did their congratulations
on that thank you Sarah
I wonder if people gonna get less
concerned about politically correct oh
yeah I think that like Jamie and I were
talking about like gender pronouns not
really call me whatever you want to call
me as long a for yeah yeah oh this would
be nice to each other and [ __ ] relax
I think that's part of what we were
going through as a culture
well the outraged culture is because it
wasn't anything real to fight against no
it was not nothing real that was a real
problem as opposed to every other single
era of humanity which is like filled
with strife in trouble
- the only one look at guns the gun
control [ __ ] that's not that's not a
conversation anymore
the window okay oh so many left-wing
people lining up to buy guns now Oh
everyone yes including my friends wives
who used to get bad if she they even
heard talk about guns they would get mad
and now they're asking that the husband
go get a gun no [ __ ] no [ __ ]
about what kind of gun what do you have
where do you keep it that kind of [ __ ]
like whoa whoa whoa
dude that's so that's that's off the
board yeah that's off the board if
people listen once refrigeration goes
that's when you see what's up once power
goes that's when you see what's up we
live in a ridiculous way we live in a
way that's only sustainable if it's
super fragile system stays in place I
mean it's robust in terms that it
handles millions and millions of people
but it's fragile in the sense that one
gigantic solar flare could wipe it out
one earthquake could wipe it out power
surges something crazy that you know
asteroid shower that hits earth wipes
out everything
there's we were not sustainable
we're only sustainable under certain
conditions and a big part of those
conditions is the power grid I wonder
how much is gonna change the way people
behave meaning Gardens chickens rabbits
like you know we should have community a
little look a little patch of garden in
every community you just have an area
you know you have it five houses have
one empty lot for five million brilliant
right one empty lot the size of a lot
that a house would be built on and then
you just grow vegetables and have
chickens even if you're a vegetarian
folks listen to me chickens you don't
hurt them when you eat their eggs
there's no hurting them at all if you if
you're if you're feeding them well their
eggs will be nutritious they're real
easy as long as there's no coyotes
around that's my number one problem that
I have is coyotes would target the
chickens but other than that you just
let them go out in the yard man they'd
find bugs to eat and worms to eat and
then their eggs are delicious and you're
not hurting them and they prefer being
in the chicken coop they go chicken coop
for safety you shut him in there you let
him out in the morning they're like they
were like my little friends it's the
best thing your wife ever did in my
entire life affecting me was convinced
my wife to get chickens to because you
you get healthy food almost every day
you get several eggs we had a high point
we had 22 chickens and we would get like
10 eggs a day every day 10 eggs and I'd
eat 6 eggs for breakfast really good
delicious
just [ __ ] nutrient-rich protein rich
and no one gets hurt
I got double yolks one time my favorite
in the world the problem is if you want
Miller chickens then you're gonna have
to have a rooster Roosters or
[ __ ] they're [ __ ] they scream
in the morning they wake up everybody
they piss off your neighbors everybody
wants me to do the chicken laying an egg
is loud yeah I'm David telling my
mancave doing a podcast was Tommy and
the chickens all of that it's really
aggressive as where the [ __ ] are we
[Laughter]
something like that where every day a
[ __ ] egg came out of your [ __ ] we
could eat it'd be so ridiculous
cuz chickens can eat their own eggs too
and you have to keep them from finding
that out really yeah yeah yeah if they
find out they'll start pecking eggs
especially eggs aren't theirs yeah you
know so if an egg falls and breaks you
got to be really careful that the
chickens don't find out about it because
once they fight look a little dinosaurs
bro oh yeah little dinosaurs you know
one of them tried to bite my youngest
daughter when she was she was very young
at the time I want to say she was
someone the neighborhood her four or
five when his chickens started pecking
her toes and my what my wife was like oh
she probably thinks her toe is a worm I
go no she's trying to eat the baby
[ __ ] [ __ ] chicken is trying to eat
the baby she doesn't think she's a worm
how come she doesn't think I'm a [ __ ]
word she just thinks that that thing is
slow enough and young enough she might
be able to eat it because chickens can
tell when things are vulnerable man
you've seen chickens with bites before
right oh yeah have you ever seen them in
real life or the mouse uh no not in real
life I've seen it several times rats run
amuck on my in our chicken coop yeah
well those chickens will turn on that
rat they can catch them they can catch
that [ __ ] in the corner they'll
tear him apart
yeah I'm not thinking about hunting rats
with my pellet gun well rats anywhere
you live in California where there's
hills and people you're infested in
fruit trees yeah fruits Weaver North
tree in our backyard and it's [ __ ]
infest just garbage cans on a regular
basis garbage cans outside yeah
and ways inside things find a way inside
your house oh I live in Encino and this
I had a place that I was renting that
was totally infested with rats it was
foul man they were big rat here running
around in the [ __ ] inside walls also
I set a trap once and I went out I saw
there's a rat and I was lazy so I went
back to bed I'm like I'll clean in the
morning I went out in the morning they'd
eaten it the rats had eaten it the rats
had eaten the other rat it was a big rat
too dude a big fat boy like a pregnant
squirrel like a fat rat a big rat and
this rat trap killed him I was like holy
[ __ ] I was tired
so I left that rat in there I went out
in the morning to go look at I was like
oh [ __ ] hold wild menagerie in my house
at that time we think about it
I got rats eating each other in the
garage I got a feral cat that I'm locked
in a room with I got two pitbulls
I got a fluff ball cat I had surrounded
with weird animals I think about I
remember hearing you talk about those
times where you come home and the dogs
would have thought over something that
happened twice came home and the dogs
were tore each other apart was horrible
what was just it was one female that I
got that I got from the pound that I got
cut because of Bryan Callen Bryan Callen
called me up it's like dude you got to
see this little puppy pitbull she's so
adorable you see you're gonna see you're
gonna fall in love with her you gotta go
see her he was at the LA Animal Shelter
Mike goddamnit
I'm like okay so I went down there I was
a [ __ ] you know so I went down there
and I saw this little thing and she's
trapped in and the LA Animal Shelter at
least at the time the place that I'm
thinking about not sure if I'm getting
the name right was a no-kill shelter so
they operated on donations they keep an
animal alive for a long time so she had
been inside this place for several
months and she was really kind of
weirded out by being in jail for that
long I'm not getting a lot of human
contact and someone I took her home and
I would pet her and loved her
she would get really aggressive with the
other dogs to keep them away from her
because she didn't get enough love when
she was younger so now that she's
finally getting love love was so
valuable that other dogs she didn't
think of other dogs as being her friends
she's thought of them as love thieves so
they would come here yeah so there was a
couple different instances that happen
and one of them happened when the pool
guy had apparently come over and then
the pool guy was petting both dogs and
one dog attacked my female my little
female attacked the bigger male to keep
him away from getting petted she didn't
want him to be pets all the pets yeah it
was just a matter look and I had a bit
about it I did for a little bit but it's
basically I had a prison dog I mean I
brought home a prison dog this dog had
been a prisoner a giant chunk of its
little life
and by the time I got it home it just
was not tolerating any [ __ ] and it
had this attitude no matter what you
couldn't it loved people
no no fear at all about it being mean to
people but around other dogs it was very
dangerous very dangerous he'd ever knew
it just it's thought of other dogs as
being thieves you know a thought of love
as being like a very valuable commodity
and other dogs are stealing her love God
man that's crazy yeah because my other
two dogs were not like that at all at
all one of them I had him since he was a
puppy and the other one I got her like
right around the time that he was a
puppy and she was only maybe a year old
herself and she was another rescue dog
and they were like best friends
so they they were fun together there how
many dogs have you had in total five at
one time I had five at one time
altogether if I could have 20 dogs I'd
have 20 dogs but it's not fair for the
dog the dog dogs need you know they
they're like family members man they
need love yeah and that's sort of like
this dog marshals different than any dog
I've ever had because he's there's zero
challenging in him there's these all's
he's not barking at anybody he's not
growling ever he's ground like to play I
could come up to you with like a
twenties mouths like and I'm like dude
you got that toy you got but his tails
Waggin like there's no aggression to him
he's just all love what was the thought
behind the German Shepherd her a gold
retriever yeah well I never had one
before but I heard they're great dogs
and I've always heard they're really
good family dogs I had a lab a black lab
McGill which was [ __ ] the greatest
dogs she's died more she dived at the
bottom of the pool and grabbed rings
yeah I mean those are dogs that people
used to hunt ducks you know those kind
of dogs there's task-oriented dogs you
could teach them to do things yeah
like martial whenever he comes over to
like like in the morning I'll get up in
the morning and always grabs a toy
always Brad grabs a toy and brings it to
like he never just comes to you and pets
you he comes to you and shows you a toy
that he's got because
his jeans are Retrievers so it's like a
bird hunting dog look someone would
shoot a pheasant or something like that
and he would grab it and bring it back
or whatever
yeah whatever bird it was and that's
that's like what he's doing and he holds
it in his mouth it brings you to show
you like he rarely tears his toys apart
she's a babe she's herself Mel's yeah
just carry morale he's a sweetie
does he go swimming yet all the time I
want to get my is he as our new bull
Mastiffs I want to get her in the books
you can tell she how was it yeah
Priscilla fell in the pool all this old
[ __ ] does she know how to swim yeah she
got out but we didn't know she fell in
she just came in and you could see this
in this dog's eyes like just you've no
[ __ ] idea what happened soaking wet
and when I how did you get wet and then
you see she fell in off the lily like
the steps and then found her way out but
man you think you got to teach the doggy
the way out of the pool yes using the
way out of the pool and hopefully you
got to have like a dog friendly pool
there's more than one ladder somewhere
where you can you know you know you
don't want to have a pool where you have
to take the dog out yourself
no yeah good you want what some what
cause it's just hard for dogs to when
they get their paws up on the concrete
to get their whole body up it's not easy
yeah it's not easy for them like it is
for us you know you get your hands on
the on the concrete on the side anywhere
you can just push yourself up and you
sit on the side the dog can't do that
dogs got to go up steps yeah unless it's
like some super dog or something but
yeah man if it was up to me I'd have
like 20 dogs I want to get Priscilla and
Mona as are the two dogs the older or
older dogs when they pass will have this
[ __ ] idiot dog Izzie thanks [ __ ]
six seven months you gotta teach him oh
yeah she just is like it's not gonna
learn man this dog has so much [ __ ]
it's like it's almost like just like
blind eye to you like huh what what are
you talking about like she's on crank
all day all [ __ ] day what kind of dog
is it bull mastiff yeah that's why those
are great protection dogs oh so much
energy she has got man something goes
down in the backyard this [ __ ] is on ya
hope right out there so sure do
she's raised for something to do that's
like when a regular person gets up
Belgian Malinois and so it's bringing
that goddamn thing around everywhere
like oh look at you you little [ __ ]
demon little black-haired even with the
Belgium assigned to take out prisoners
is that the [ __ ] it's like a German
Shepherd looking dogs yeah exactly
exactly the German champion looking dog
but they look so fierce man those dogs
there we had we used them a bunch of
times on fear factor look at the [ __ ]
athleticism of this tank this [ __ ]
can go to the roof look at take this guy
down
they're wild dogs man it turns with
their athleticism look at that thing fly
up that grab well have you seen them one
where there's uh there's a treat or a
ball hanging from a tree and so this
Belgian Malinois jumps runs up the side
of the trunk of the tree and then leaps
sideways like 20 feet in the air to
snatch this ball look at this look at
this thing walking on her you've
tightrope across two buildings bro you
don't want nothing to do with this dog
that is a dog that was clearly not
trained in America it's going backwards
now you don't want jack [ __ ] to do with
this dog you just you just do not yeah
you can't let that [ __ ] go there
amazing look at that oh my god dude how
about that how about it jumping over
this guy's back and jumping into the bed
of that truck as its speeding those
trees look at the [ __ ] athleticism
these things have and you really only
get that kind of athleticism with a dog
that's like that size you know it's not
a giant dog yeah like what do you think
that weighs I don't think they're very
big sixty pounds yeah probably sixty or
seventy pounds for you know good-sized
one although we were just talking the
other day about someone who had one that
was really young and it was already 90
pounds
somebody had one it was like who was
that though saying that has one that was
like six months old it was already 90
pounds was it Andy was talking about
somebody yeah so the average is like 75
pounds for a male that's like that's on
the high end so this guy had one that
was already 90 pounds that was six
months old so
they also had doubled canines the ones
that he was showing us like great whites
like on each side they have two canines
on the top so you could find that image
double canines Belgian Malinois that's
the thing they're breeding they're
making hybrids you know like they take a
grapefruit they mix it with a orange
[Laughter]
grapple together a grape look it's got
double canines shut yeah some of them
have two canines I couldn't live with
the dog I almost bought a dog of
Argentino and the guy was like right
before I bought it he was like hey
you're gonna have this dog in bed with
you and I go yeah of course he goes I'm
not selling it to you mommy really yeah
because you got it there's certain dogs
where you have to become the master like
like dog origin Tino's are like bull
Mastiffs but pit bulls on steroids yeah
and the guy was like yeah man if it once
gets in bed with you you've lost the
house good call man thank you for
stopping me I'm running this house [ __ ]
[ __ ] my wife I'm like I imagine he
starts growling while he's humping your
wife's leg oh no what have I done I let
this giant beast get too comfortable in
my house 200 pound [ __ ] your wife look
at the build on that thing that's the
most beautiful dog I've ever seen in my
life it looks like it the clown if it
was an evil dog it does look like it
does go back to that picture it looks
like it looks like that's one that's
Pennywise the clown oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] Pennywise I'm so glad I
didn't get one now doesn't it look at
that [ __ ] dog oh my god the muscle
and the thing of preposterous when was
the last time you got attacked by a dog
I've never been attacked by a dog oh
Jesus that's that looks like the rock if
it was a dog look at that build on that
thing look at that man
is Christ and that's why 130 pounds
that's a girl - that's a female dog try
to try to grab on to any part of that
dog to stop it from killing you good
luck there's not one part of you that
looks like a demon like a sweet-faced
demon you got wandering around your yard
looking to kill burglars that's the dog
I wanted whoo build on that [ __ ] Jesus
Christ that's that is a crazy dog to
have around your house like you got to
really be on top of things
look at that head with the collar look
at that one in the middle oh my god look
it's almost hard that dogs so ready God
bro that's a polar bear that's like
having a polar bear how is that any
different how's it any different those
those and Connie Corsos are [ __ ]
that's the [ __ ] with dogs yeah
if my wife leaves me I'm moving to
Malibu I'm getting that kind of course
one Adana dog origin Tino yeah those
[ __ ] oh look at the [ __ ] muscles
in the chest for that thing come on man
that's just too weird yeah if I feel
like if you have a dog like that also
it's like you have this obligation to
work that [ __ ] out every day
every day that isn't you have a super
athlete you just can't have that thing
into your yard being bored like that's a
different kind of dog that's why that's
why he was like you're not letting in
bed with you I was like of course yeah
why running [ __ ] son you got to keep
those [ __ ] on a leash and train
them well from the time they're really
young or or get one that's trained but
even then I've won I've heard about like
Belgian Malinois Zin particularly like
you got to be the boss like that thing
has to respect the ER this that was is
that what Cal or a shop got to his wife
at all it was like [ __ ] you [ __ ] and
she's like oh no I got those crazy dog
on my house it's not listening day yeah
but if a dog thinks you're not the boss
then it becomes the boss like he decided
Brendan was the boss like leave this big
[ __ ] with the deep voice you
know he's six foot five or whatever he
is
yeah he's gigantic and so he's around
this dogs like hey bro I'm the dogs like
okay big guy
[Laughter]
with um the wife's around like who [ __ ]
you who you where's the big guy I think
I'm the big guy [ __ ] like that's
why you have to get a dog when it's a
puppy you know when you get a dog when
it's a puppy then you know you're the
daddy like when I get up in the morning
and Marshalls waiting for me I'm like
bro
so I say to him bro and it's like
running around in circles and [ __ ] like
it's a healthy relationship like he's
for his whole life he's associated me
with going on runs and getting belly
rubs and you know playing so yeah it's
like when a dog you get a dog when it's
fully grown like you have no idea what
that was going on you don't know what
was going on you didn't you weren't
there you don't know it was going on
you're getting a two-year-old dog that's
trained and trained how by hoo-wee there
you can assume from some guys because
you trust their reputation they're
really good at raising dogs but it's not
the same relationship as when you raise
a dog from the time it's a puppy no
puppies are yeah and there's nothing
better that the dog we have now got me
because I was in Phoenix doing the show
my wife's like am I watched on the road
with me she goes hey there's a puppy
like 20 miles from here and I went to
the house walked in and this [ __ ] dog
climbed up in my lap laid her head on my
shoulder and just went to sleep and I
went bait you're going home with us it's
to their two adorable puppies like are
the cutest thing that you ever get to
experience other than a baby and maybe
even more than a baby because you're not
as you're not as concerned about them
being vulnerable so you could appreciate
them more sometimes less it's your baby
once your baby you're just so full of
love you don't know what the [ __ ] to do
but other people's babies are pretty
cute but other people's puppies are
always cute or they're so adorable
there's something about a puppy even the
way they move the move kind of funny
front paw jump right love like yeah just
having fun and what sucks is where we're
at now with this puppy where it's still
a puppy but it's big and you're like you
know you cannot just jump up on the
[ __ ] bed and [ __ ] just like she's
ever given it lessons do you give it
lessons on
I haven't been home for a while but I
was thinking to start they must start
giving this [ __ ] dogs a blessings
make the rules man you're gonna make the
rules oh she is she is she's [ __ ]
hilarious but man she gets up like just
gets up on your lap like you should have
rooms for the dogs not allowed to go in
okay dude I'll be taking [ __ ] and this
dog will walk in the closet grab his
shoe and just walk out look at me and go
she learned how to open the trash can
like pull cabinet and just stick her in
the try to go Izzie should go huh what
don't even say no just yeah you got a
trainer Bert before it's too late it
might be too late
there might be this might be even you
might need to bring in Cesar Millan for
this one I ran into Cesar Millan the
other night you need to run into him
it's fate where was I stop you from
being a future episode of his show what
the [ __ ] man oh yeah I can't do that
Bert that's ridiculous
where was that mammoth Cesar Millan
where were you that's a good question
[ __ ] I must have been somewhere and like
like some sort of event I don't know but
you need to have him help you fix your
[ __ ] dog yeah this [ __ ] dog is all
over the map dude it's 3330 you sure
yeah
oh [ __ ] we've been going for what we've
been going three and a half hours
ridiculous this is awesome
I'm so glad that would all this
craziness we could still do something
like this [ __ ] yeah social distancing
yes just we're not making out anymore
and I hope you guys at home listen and
stay safe and and Bert Kreischer hey big
boys available right now let's break the
internet you [ __ ]
please available right now on the
Netflix go there and joy and that's it
Bert Kreischer on Instagram Bert
Kreischer on Twitter do you even use
Twitter anymore yeah I do do you pay
attention to the mean people no I read
it without my glasses so I can see what
just loving her tweet well thank you
brother I love in two minutes always
thank you always fun bye everybody we
see soon
[Music]